thank you Pete appreciate the great
introduction
appreciate each and every one of you
being here all the near the holidays and
everything appreciate you
now just asked a couple of questions so
I know who I'm talking to so I don't
have to be redundant uh how many of you
have heard me speak live before
okay all the Believers are over here all
the new ones are over here very good
all right
just like church and then
um
yeah don't open them now while I'm
talking please call it crunchy crinkly
stuff yeah give it back to him
don't give out crunchy things while I'm
talking okay
potato chips are dead Okay
um
I know there's at least one Healthcare
professional in here any others yes what
did you do
okay very good
and where'd you go to school all right
fabulous
are you a Seventh-Day Adventist I'm not
okay
very good
anybody else a healthcare professional
yes sir
chiropractor love you guys whoa
what's your average age
it's death
he became a lawyer
oh my gosh we'll forgive you forgive him
Lord all right
um
appreciate everybody being here and just
for those who don't know me very well
basically the thing that makes my view
different on health is I have a degree
in agriculture my major is an animal
husbandry and nutrition my minor was in
field crops and soils you learn about
soil nutrition and plant physiology and
that kind of stuff I went to veterinary
school became a veterinarian became a
comparative pathologist got a postdoc
and compared pathology worked with
Marlon Perkins from the old Mutual Omaha
Wild Kingdom days
in the center for the biology of natural
systems Washington University in St
Louis that one project was an NIH
project looking to see a pollution had
any impact upon Health kind of
prevention kind of stuff
and actually uh wound up doing some 20
000 autopsies at one project some uh 17
000 and some change in over 454 species
of zoo animals and three thousand human
beings uh the second project in China
with Dr Milan and we did 1 700 autopsies
on kids that are under age 10 that died
of a single disease which we'll talk
about in a minute
and um
again you'll know why later but I went
back to school and became a primary care
physician as a naturopathic physician
we've been licensed in California for
about five years now my license in
California is zero six one so I'm very
proud of that I got below a hundred okay
now
with all that said
um you've come here for some information
on health I'm assuming and what you're
going to hear hear
h-e-a-r-h-e-r-e what you're going to
hear here is something that's 180
degrees from what you've been taught
this is based on the animal industry
because in the animal industry we don't
have health insurance
and by not having health insurance a
veterinarian is obligated to cure the
animal very quickly one or two visits
otherwise the owner doesn't bring them
back or the farmer doesn't call you back
they just eat the cow eat the pig
they're not going to do a hip
replacement on a chicken you know that
kind of stuff so you have to fix them
very quickly and there's no insurance to
pay for long-term therapy and humans on
the other hand the worst possible thing
that could have happened for a human
health is Insurance you'll see why in a
moment
and it's the worst possible thing that
could have happened
and um so this is going to impact how
the presentation goes if you would even
though we have a small sort of um
intimate crowd here we'll have plenty of
time for Q a afterwards so if you just
hold the comments and questions until
then I'll be be sure we get that done
people always ask me why do you come up
with the title Dead Doctors Don't Lie
back in 1992 I actually did a survey
through the journal American Medical
Association I read 200 of those issues
of uh for like
10 years previous added up all the
obituaries in there then divided by the
200 magazines and the average was 58 and
I said why would you go to a group of
people whose average lifespan is 58 to
learn how to live the 100 in a healthful
way
and so people say well
well why is that and I said well only
Dead Doctors Don't Lie that's it just
came out of my mouth so that's where the
title came from
let's go back to the beginning
whatever that was there's all kinds of
argument when the beginning was but in
the beginning when people began to
ponder on these things
everybody thought the disease was caused
by evil spirits if you burn enough goats
to the good spirits they would protect
you from the bad spirits if you didn't
burn enough goats or some of your
enemies would burn more goes to the bad
spirits they'd put evil spells on you
get plagues and disease and that kind of
stuff and even doctors bought into that
back in the old days
how long have human beings been around
well the Bible doesn't really tell you
it just says there's a progression
the earth was formed and then the
gaseous stuff turned into water and then
there were plants and then there were
animals and there were people so we
really don't know and a lot of people
will guess at various ages I've found it
kind of fascinating they were working
and this just came out December a third
of this year 2013 and what they did was
they were digging a hole in Spain to
build some big building and they ran
into a cave that nobody knew about they
found 28 full skeletons and they knew
they were human beings because they took
DNA the DNA was still recognizable
because we had the genome come out in
2001 and the DNA in these 28 skeletons
was human
and
they dated them using argon and carbon
dating 300 000 years ago
no would you believe that or not doesn't
bother me because I don't know whether
to believe it or not but that's what
their dating system said all I know is
that I believe that everything on Earth
was created by God so it doesn't matter
what we think about when it was formed
Earth it's it's all formed by him so who
cares the date but anyway they said 300
000 years ago that's when they started
thinking about evil spirits
we know
that there's different types of human
beings just like there are today and
there's different uh you know species or
varieties or types of dogs and cats and
so for the same thing it's true of
people
and again from skeletons they find in
caves and they do
um
DNA
maternal
um
DNA
and paternal DNA and all those kind of
stuff they found out
so these guys were sort of swingers
they found that one father was having
babies from 20 different types of human
beings he was a traveling salesman
probably right and so that was kind of
fascinating I thought
um that they could tell from the from
the female mitochondria who was doing
what and so forth back in those days in
certain areas I thought that was kind of
fascinating
then of course eventually people began
to believe in one God instead of lots of
gods and things and they built huge
structures this is one rendition of the
Tower of Babel and of course this was
meant to be where people could pray and
knowledge was accumulated and so forth
and
and these things all fell even though
they were Grand edifices they fell into
just dust because they really weren't
the answer to to what caused the
diseases and the other but it was man's
attempt to try and find out and how to
control those things
then religion really got into the deal
and there was a there was a difficulty
in determining
whether a person was a priest or a
or a physician a lot of them were both
in those days in the old days
um
and so it was kind of interesting
and then again
they found some wondrous things
in these old caves some of these cave
drawings I probably should move this
farther up front the old cave drawings
or 28th that are dated carbon dating 28
000 years ago
and right after the second world war
like in 1946 Pablo Picasso was taken in
there these French caves and he came out
and he said and he's crying he's weeping
which is humility he said those people
28 000 years ago knew more than we know
now just think about it the pigments
they put together
lasted 28 000 years
hit the Patriot house every five years
okay so they knew stuff now whether they
knew the chemistry or not probably not
but they knew that some stuff lasted and
some stuff didn't and they're quite
clever back if that's true dating 28 000
years ago some of them different
pictures they say went back as far as 32
000 years ago
foreign
then people began to realize that there
were herbs and all kinds of weird stuff
that would help people with health and
Alchemy how many of you heard of alchemy
okay this is where they want to
transmute
lead into gold that kind of stuff those
kind of people and they felt that if a
person could learn how to convert these
were the spiritual ones these were in
the beginning before they were
charlatans and all that kind of stuff
but in the beginning they said you know
if we know enough to convert lead into
gold which is kind of a god-like
practice turning lead into gold
we should be able to come up with What's
called the Panacea and the Panacea was
the cure for everything
that was the goal of the spiritual ones
in the beginning the Alchemists their
whole goal was to find the Panacea the
cure-all thing the one silver bullet
that would cure everything okay so
that's what Alchemy was about
then Along Came
along 1800s
two people one was called Charles Darwin
the other one Gregor Mendel how many of
you heard of Charles Darwin okay good
let me heard of Gregor Mendel okay well
Gregor Mendel is an interesting guy he
was a monk uh and
uh he a Trappist Monk and he lived on
these little farms and the bishop picked
him for whatever reason to run
um hot houses so they could have peas
during the winter time all the priests
the Catholic priests wanted
um appease during the winter time so
um Gregor Mendel was appointed to run
these hot houses and grow peas well he
had several varieties had red flowered
ones and white flowered ones every once
while pink flowered ones would show up
and he'd breed the pink flower ones back
to the white flowered ones and they
would always come out white and he'd
breed the pink ones back to the red
flowers and they'd always come out red
but he breed two penguins together you
get pink and so he learned about
recessives and dominance in the early
1800s he didn't know the words and he
didn't know the science and everything
but he was recording he was a
mathematician by training and so he
recorded all this stuff one to four and
all the stuff we know about genetics
today Gregor Mendel came up with that in
the early 1800s Darwin did not know
about him the Gregor Mendel knew about
Darwin okay and Darwin
most people don't know
about him although they've heard of him
they really don't know much about him
why was he chosen to be the guy to sail
around the world on the HMS Beagle he
was chosen he didn't rent a ship
why was he chosen
well
he was chosen to go around the world
because he had written several
papers and biology journals on the
polyps that make reefs
the British Navy had trouble with their
ships in these Harbors which were deep
enough to be good Harbors for the ships
but when a wind would come it'd blow the
ships up on the shore and uncontrollably
erect them and all this kind of stuff
and they read his stuff and they said
you know this guy can build artificial
reefs into these Harbors because he
knows how reefs are formed by these
little polyps he knew how they
reproduced and how they he knew the
chemistry of how they they actually put
together these reefs so they hired him
for two years to go around and build
these reefs to protect and shelter these
deep water Harbors that the British Navy
had their ships
and he was so successful at it they
hired him for another three years so in
the five years he was working on the HMS
Beagle he went around the world five
times nobody even Christ didn't go
around the world five times as a human
being Christ only stayed in the Middle
East right well here's this guy goes
around the world he sees things that
nobody else on Earth has ever seen
he writes them all down he collects
bird eggs that have been cracked open
the bird hatches out he cracked you know
he collects the bird eggs he gives the
he shoots him and and taxidermies him
and he saves feathers he collects all
these plants he has a botanist and a
burger and all these kind of things he's
a farmer uh he was he went to medical
school I mean this guy was very
knowledgeable he was one of the first
people they call it polymath how many of
you heard of the term polymath okay good
well Darwin was one of the first people
called the polymath because he was an
expert in so many different fields they
chose the right guy they didn't know it
but they chose the right guy to make
these trips and he would see stuff like
this
the chin strapped
um breed of penguins
the Antarctic these Southern islands in
the Atlantic just below the Antarctic
Circle
or just above it depending on how you're
facing right it was just a miracle he'd
see this stuff and from a farmer from
England to see stuff like this he just
blew his mind and he's he's collecting
these things and you know killing a few
and skinning them and Taxidermy and put
them all together and he realized that
no matter what it was whether it was
Penguins or giraffes in Africa or human
beings and different types of human
beings from the island people and so
forth that everybody passed on
information
get two redheads they'll always have
redheaded kids
now if a black-haired person has a baby
with a red-headed person those kids will
always be black-haired unless the
black-haired guy had a relative way back
there was redhead and so every fourth
baby would come out a redhead and so and
he and Charles Darwin is kind of like
Gregor Mendel with his pea plants as I
say the Gregor Mendel knew about his
stuff but he but Darwin didn't know
about Gregor Mendel so all this is kind
of happening and the information is
being collected he he wrote it up in
papers and then of course
Darwin wrote his famous book right the
Origin of Species
now
Darwin when he wrote the Origin of
Species which is in the early 1800s
about 1838 something like that
his cousin
got the name of Francis Galton how many
of you heard of Francis Galton ooh bad
guy okay now Francis Galton started
something he started a a kind of a
pseudoscience in the beginning where he
was measuring people's heads and trying
to determine their intelligence and that
kind of stuff but he called his science
Eugenics how many of you heard of
eugenics okay
well Eugenics make a long story short
wound up being this
okay now remember Hitler is trying to
make the perfect Race by killing off all
the ones who are imperfect for whatever
reason
that was galton's Theory because Dalton
was Darwin's cousin he was a very
wealthy guy he dropped out of medical
school twice because he inherited the
farm he inherited his father's money he
says why should I be looking at people's
hemorrhoids
I'm a gentleman farmer so I'm going to
do something else so he came up with a
sign saying you know
we can speed up human evolution
because he knew about selective breeding
for cows and horses and sheep and pigs
and chickens and stuff like that you
know you have a cow that doesn't give
much milk you eater
you have a cow that gives a lot of milk
you save all her female calves and breed
them in hopes of getting that
information more cows giving more milk
kind of thing that's called selective
breeding he says we'll do that with
humans and he was sort of a
compassionate guy and so he didn't start
out killing people but he started out
with a with a a dating Club is what
essentially it was the first dating club
and all he wanted to come to these
dating clubs he invited them through the
newspapers and that kind of stuff didn't
have the internet and radio he just
threw newspaper ads he had his dating
club and all he wanted to attract was
tall blonde-haired blue-eyed people kind
of sound familiar
okay now
and by 19
04 1910 in there every state in the
United States had a Eugenics office in
every state
the federal government had a eugenics
Department
and between 1895 and 1930
the American government paid doctors to
forcibly sterilize 400 000 Americans who
they considered people feeble-minded
illiterate uh people who had birth
defects people who were habitual Petty
criminals you know shoplifters and kind
of stuff like that and the sheriffs
would go out and grab them take them to
the doctor give the doctor 100 Bill and
they'd sterilize them
doctors loved it
they were willing participants they
never said now wait a minute here you
better show me a court order they just
took 100 bucks and cut their testicles
off or did a hysterectomy on them
400 000 Americans were forcibly
sterilized
every country in Europe had a Eugenics
Department
it kind of went crazy
well Hitler was in jail for 20 years and
guess what he read in that 20 years in
jail all of Francis Galton stuff and all
Charles Darwin stuff when he came out he
was an expert on eugenics
and he wanted to build Germany into the
perfect race because we had cut Germany
up after the first world war so it could
never be a world power again
Germany used to run before the first
world war all the way from from Russia
all the way to Spain
all the other countries like
Czechoslovakia and Hungary and Poland
were provinces in in Germany
Germany was the biggest
European country in Europe
it was huge it was bigger than all of
them combined
and that's why they were so powerful
well they broke them up you know the
League of Nations after the first world
war so that would never happen again
well they're all starmin so it's easy
when Hitler got out of jail
the the Kaiser made him Chancellor
without even an election
he says Hitler save us
Taylor says I will
we just have to get rid of the riffraff
he starts killing people
we have to take over the world
why
I have radio interviews of him I have
all his speeches he used to give to his
troops he'd say things like
if we Superior people don't take over
the Earth
the insects will wind up eating us all
so we have to kill out the ones that are
inferior and only breed those that are
superior
because you've been reading Francis
Galton stuff and Charles Darwin's stuff
for 20 years in prison okay so that's
where this came from
I think you get the picture here so
we're going to get into science now
but I just want to kind of give you that
little background and you'll begin to
recognize some of the stuff as we go
through here based on everything I've
just showed you
foreign
this is a cover article Time Magazine
came out in December
of 2008.
we Americans each year
according to the World Health
Organization according to the Center for
Disease Control the Department of Health
and Human Services the federal
government the Senate the house we spend
more money each year for health care
than all the countries in the world
combined there's 204 Nations registered
in the United Nations we spend more
money for Health Care each year than all
the world combined what do we get for it
we're 92nd in healthfulness there's 91
other nations whose peoples are healthy
enough we're 60th in longevity there's
59 other nations whose peoples live
longer than us and God forgive us who
rank 41st who comes alive births and
first month's survivability of our
babies
you didn't tolerate this in any other
industry
the reason why you tolerate it
is because there's insurance
why should I spend two bucks out of my
own pocket when insurance will pay for
everything
I don't care if it kills me or killed my
mom and three of my kids it's free
and soccer to me give it to me
you know when you put a new roof on your
house you get three bids don't you check
the Better Business Bureau to see if
there's complaints about their services
you put rugs in your house you get three
bids and you
checked A Better Business Bureau
get Landscaping done and they're putting
in sprinkler systems you get three Biz
you call the Better Business Bureau your
doctor who's been your doctor for 20
years says you know you got a bad heart
I'm going to cut your heart out and put
some dead guy's heart in you say Okay
insurance will pay
is that insane or is that insane
well the title of this article is the
sorry state of American Health despite
advances in medicine despite
technological advances in medicine
Americans are less healthy than we used
to be remember this is
December 2008
five years ago
despite advances technological Advanced
medicine Americans are less healthy when
they used to be the most important part
of the sentence is the next show is your
kids are going to be worse off now raise
your hand if you've heard that our kids
are not going to live as long as us
okay that's at least 60 70 of the people
in the room now
that's a horrifying thought to
understand that according to all the
records
it shows that we rank 41st in the world
despite all this money we're putting out
we ranked 41st the world for live births
and first month survivability babies and
that doesn't include abortions or
anything like that that's just natural
births and so on
and what they're saying is 75 percent of
American couples who have babies are
going to be standing a grave site
burying their babies
I cannot imagine a more horrifying
thing to contemplate is to be burying a
young child
from something was totally preventable
let me give you screwy numbers I threw
this one in
October 2011 and ranking of live births
and newborn deaths we rank 41st they
said it's USA Shane
now that's absolutely positively not
true
you put up more money than all the
countries in the world put together
it's not your shame
is to Providers of the services Shane
Veterinary records are not that bad
somebody needs to go to jail
Okay the reason why this happens is
there's no consequences
1914 exactly 100 years ago there's a
report that was commissioned by the
Rockefeller institution and the
Carnegie Institute
it was called the flexor report
the flexion report was a report that was
made by a retired College president who
was hired by The Rockefellers and the
carnegies to go around look at all the
132 medical schools and classify them
they found that out of the 132 of them a
hundred of them were herbal schools
homeopathic schools Chiropractic schools
that kind of stuff they said you know
they're just Hokey Pokey schools the
real schools the 32 that are left the
medical schools are the ones that use
prescription drugs course Rockefeller
like that because they're all made out
of petroleum right he liked that
and so they didn't hurt directly the 100
homeopathic schools and herbal schools
and official schools and that kind of
stuff but what they did do is pour
millions of dollars which is like
trillions of dollars a day it poured
millions of dollars in these 32 medical
schools and all the students went that
direction
that's where all the Keen new tools were
that's where the best professors were
that's where the money was at everybody
got a grant to go there for nothing
because the Rockefellers and the
carnegies were saying hey when they get
out of school they're going to get our
prescriptions out there to the public
well at that time
at that time put your keys in your purse
because you're rattling your teeth
could you move one more map please yeah
you need to move this way too because
you're in front of the camera
thank you
so you have to edit that
so
basically 100 years ago almost to the
date
not only did the what we would call
Orthodox medical schools
get all this money and and Rose to the
top not because of skill and benefit to
their patients just because of money
they also legislated themselves into
being a protective Monopoly either the
only legal Monopoly in America is the
medical school
MD medicine
they're the only legal Monopoly in
America everybody else is a quack just
ask them
by legislation they legislated all their
competition all their legitimate
competition into being fifth class
citizens citizens
insurance doesn't pay for quacks and
fifth class citizens they only pay MDS
when you look at the military you look
at the government they only recognize MD
so they have this huge problem
because the skills at one MD has are
similar to the skills another one has
there's not much difference between them
and so it doesn't matter if they're a
nice guy and they go to church that's
meaningless
because they all use the same medicine
I'll use the same procedures
so there's no options
and that's why we're in trouble
okay
now remember we already all agreed or at
least 70 percent of us agreed that our
kids are in trouble
because if you think we're in trouble
our kids are a thousand times more
trouble than we are
the age group is has the fastest growing
rate of Ms multiple Scrolls since her
kids under the age of 12. they're now
diagnosing Ms and kids under the age of
two 16 months 18 months historically it
was a disease of 35 to 50 year olds
middle-aged people
what's going on here well this is free
radical damage to the myelin the
insulation material in the brain
and after school
Remo takes
the six-year-old or the 10 year old to
one of these fast food places and gets
them a shake
it's not a milkshake it's made out of
oil it's you know one of these
soft serves
shakes
it's oil free radical damage it oxidizes
turns into trans fatty acids and screws
up their brains so now Grandma's the one
who's inflicting
out of ignorance she's inflicting Ms on
these little kids
because they're free radical damage to
the brains
here's a NASCAR driver he and his three
brothers and sisters
all have MS
it's not genetic but his mother made
sure they all had salads and put olive
oil in everything
olive oil coconut oil trans fatty acids
free radicals bam you have MS
the whole family's got it because Mama
insisted they eat salads and make sure
they put lots of vinegar and oil on
their salads
but but but but my doctor said that was
healthy well your doctor only lives to
be 56 why would you believe him
when it comes to stroke
the age group that has the fastest
growing rate of stroke in the United
States there are kids under the age of
18.
stroke is not genetic stroke doesn't
just happen it's not the bad God on Mars
creating stroke because you didn't burn
enough goats to him
the reason why people have strokes is a
simple deficiency or a ratio problem
between Omega-3s sixes and nines
how many of you supplement your
two-year-olds with Omega-3s I don't see
any hands going up one maybe
it's your responsibility because doctors
know nothing about nutrition nothing
you're better off asking a hobo under
the bridge whose dumpster diving behind
McDonald's
when it comes to nutrition
because he'll live longer than the
doctor it's crazy that sounds they live
longer than doctor
now the fastest growing disease today in
the industrialized World in kids is
rickets
say physician cause disease
let's see stay out of the Sun
get skin cancer put on SPF 7 billion
sunblocker long sleeves gloves big brim
hats shades don't go out after nine in
the morning you stay inside until after
Dark
stay inside doing your twittering and
texting and making you know all your
computer stuff
don't you eat egg yolks because you can
get cholesterol damage your heart
that's where you find vitamin D3
naturally don't you take vitamins and
minerals
you can overdose
this is a physician-caused disease it's
a perfect storm everything doctors have
told you about nutrition is the cause
right now of every industrialized Nation
the worst possible nutritional
deficiency disease in kids is rickets
rickets the 21st century
because doctors know nothing about
nutrition
foreign
briefly about birth defection I'm going
to take off my jacket it's going to
warming up in here or I'm getting warmed
up to one another
um
no that's fine thanks I would get no
wrinkle stuff
I've traveled to my channel I get no
but anyway
there's about 500 birth defects
congenital events
none of them are caused by genetics
there's not a single birth defect that's
caused by genetic transmission not a
single one we've learned this in the
animal industry we can prevent every
birth defects you can name and 10 times
that many you can by giving perfect
preconception nutrition of the females
in humans we wait until they missed a
period or two you know I might be
pregnant go and get checked out yeah
here's some pre-nailed items as well six
weeks has already gone by that embryo
has been at risk for six weeks
somebody needs to go to jail and it's
usually the OB GYN because there's no
consequences to a failed pregnancy what
if every time an OB GYN was in charge of
ladies Health female problems and he
says okay I'm going to be in charge of
your pregnancies
and there's a baby barn with a defect
there should be a penalty for him
throw a few in jail hang a few guess
what I guarantee it wouldn't be any more
birth defects after that
but now there's no consequences so they
don't care
let's look at homosexuals and gay
Behavior
let's look at
another class
of
sexual problems what about intersex how
many of you heard of intersex not
intercourse but intersex what about
um hermaphrodites that's another name
for intersexes hermaphrodites they have
both the male and female parts
and back and before the days of the
um ultrasound where they could look now
they could look at a baby at three four
months along they can tell you the
gender Arthur hermaphrodite back in the
old days they had to wait till the baby
is born what is it oh my God just both
well they do
well first thing they would do is take a
blood smear
they'd look for bar bodies
bar bodies show up whoops that's a
Russian version
bar bodies would show up in the females
okay there's these little dots on the
inside of the nucleus particularly white
blood cells these little spots here you
can see the arrow pointing to them
they're called bar bodies they don't
exist in the male X y's but they exist
in females XX because they represent uh
one of the two x chromosomes
and so when they would you know the
baby's still being wiped off in the
delivery room they take the blood Square
they run in look under the microscope
they say okay there's bar bodies there
genetically this baby is a female which
is true
so they cut the penis off cut the
testicles off and they do a little
plastic surgery to make them totally a
female uh-oh maybe he's 10 years old up
here the baby's a boy
because there's two things going on when
it comes to sex one is the DNA what you
are and then there's the pre-optic
hypothalamus
which covers eating drives depression
sexual drives and all that kind of stuff
and when you have a a child that's born
from a
congenital event let's call it a
congenital event
if they're a homosexual or a gay male or
a lesbian woman
they have about 30 percent of the cells
that a heterosexual has in that
pre-optic hypothalamus do you actually
count the cells you don't even need to
know anything else you just count the
cells as they're below a certain level
they're going to be lesbian or gay
because mama was missing something in
the first three weeks of pregnancy when
that part of the brain was being formed
OB GYN didn't Warner she's out there
having a great time
went out of 700 babies is born with
sexual problems
that happened in the first three weeks
of pregnancy it's not a choice it is not
a choice
they're driven to be homosexual gay or
lesbian
from the time they're three weeks old in
pregnancy
you can't pray them well
because it was determined that three
weeks is an embryo
you understand what I'm telling you
this is based on 600 autopsies of gay
and lesbian people
so
um I love stuff like this this is a
brilliant move I don't agree with most
of President Obama's
stuff his policies but this was
beautiful
the Russians have a big thing against
gay people so who's he send over there
for the Olympics to represent us
a gay athlete I love it I mean that was
a brilliant move
these people are wonderful people right
there's 10 times more
heterosexual
um
what am I talking about with the
heterosexuals who are pedophils
pedophiles
there's 10 times more heterosexuals who
are pedophils than our gay people
okay so you can't say Well they're a
pedophilia you can't do that because
it's not true okay so I thought this is
a brilliant move
and I was up in Canada this is a
wonderful tear-jerkin story here's two
guys they're married for 65 years
won that at 94 the other one died at 96.
two old uncles they just harmless and
you know just for great members of the
community and church members and did all
kinds of things in the Rotary Club and
the Lions Club and all that kind of
stuff and uh
how can you say anything wrong with him
they're just wonderful human beings your
mama just screwed up
why because the OB GYN screwed up
now for those who don't know a lot of
neural Anatomy
this is kind of a
rendition of a human brain
so I can clarify this for you here
this would hear the hypothalamus that
arrow is pointing right to the pre-optic
hypothalamus the part of the brain
that's
underdeveloped called hypoplasia
which means underdeveloped
and when it's underdeveloped they're
going to be a homosexual male or gay
male or a lesbian female it's
predictable as Gravity You Can Count the
cells you know
okay
now I do want to jump in here
for a moment
unless somebody copy these things and
they bent them all up so I'm never going
to let that happen again okay but I do
want to show you a couple more things
here when it comes to congenital events
in the human brain
I think it's important for you to know
this because we're the parents and
grandparents
is not God versus science
because God invented everything even
science right
1953 these two guys
one guy was an American James Watson the
other guy was a British guy
Francis Crick
Watson and Crick 1953 they came up with
the double helix structure of DNA nine
years later 1962 they got the Nobel
Prize for it
they really thought they had got had it
figured out they said we now know what
God knows about Humanity was our quote
all we have to do is is be able to
figure out how to make the normal Gene
replace the bad Gene we could cure every
disease
of course here's a chromosome
really cool these are telomeres those
will become important a little bit later
telomeres okay these determine how often
this chromosome will be able to
duplicate okay as it duplicates these
get shorter and shorter and one of the
things for longevity is to figure out
how to keep them from getting shorter
and shorter
okay so remember that
but
back in the old days rich people royalty
very wealthy merchants used to make
collections of birth defects cleft
palate cleft lips spina bifida
hydrocephalocele the brain was hanging
out of the head
um too many fingers not enough arms and
all that kind of stuff they would save
them and bottles of wine and alcohol and
stuff kind of a collector's item my
collection is bigger your collection
kind of thing and those collections at
30 000 babies like that sixty thousand
babies you find them in all the European
medical schools they go back thousands
of years those collections
hire her of identical twins
now come on I'm asked that again raise
your hand how many are okay that's
better identical twins
I think identical twins would be
identical but they're not DNA wise are
identical
DNA wise are identical you can't tell
the difference you do DNA testing
they're exactly the same when you look
at them these two look like sisters to
me they don't look identical this one's
an inch shorter than that one this one's
face is wider this one's face is longer
um you know she sharper her face is
longer look at that
okay this is kind of a crazy situation
their hairlines are different and so
they look like sisters to me this one
being the older one would be my guess if
I didn't know they're identical twins
this whole issue the National Geographic
goes into this it says twins alike but
not alike
this goes back to the term epigenetics
how many of you heard of epigenetics
okay a couple of us okay epigenetics
you'll learn that term okay epigenetics
are things that influence higher genes
perform
okay
your genes Do not sit in isolation you
can't take a handful of genes and throw
them in these would be perfect jeans and
just duplicate perfectly right you take
a handful of these perfect jeans throw
them into a bucket of saline Solutions
say Okay jeans go to it duplicate it's
gonna be like the tar baby they ain't
gonna do nothing
because they need raw materials
substrates they need energy
right they need all kinds of stuff they
need cofactors make things work
any of those things missing they don't
work
you put food on a table this twins can
eat differently than that twin even
though the same food is on the table I
don't like icky broccoli oh I love
broccoli you know kind of stuff and so
they affect how their genes will react
based on what they're eating or not
eating
now the first 91 days of pregnancy
everything is farmed the embryo the
human embryo the animal embryo is moving
along assembly line kind of like the
Ford cars and if the guy who's supposed
to be putting on the the fuel pump into
the engine you know has to go bathroom
even take a pee he goes back in the back
and he doesn't stop the line doesn't say
hey come fill in for me while I'm doing
that he might come out in 15 cars are
going by then
so at the end of the line there's 15
cars without a fuel pump
because one of the pieces was missing
during that time right well the same
thing is happening to human babies
after the first 91 days when the baby's
farming everything else is just growth
by 91 days you've got what you got there
ain't going back there are some
exceptions but not many
Sarah Palin whether you liked her
politics or not she was a sexually
active woman who is over 45 years of age
very high risk of having a Down Syndrome
baby
now her OB GYN should be put in jail
forever
because he should have said to her you
know Sarah you're gonna be out on the
road out there eating Hotel food and
Rubber Chickens and all this kind of
stuff she'll be taking some serious
vitamins minerals because at your age
you're still cycling you're sexually
active you better be taking the 90
essential nutrients you better be taking
all known essential nutrients otherwise
you're at a high risk to have a baby
with Down Syndrome the OBGYN never said
that
never offered her any advice
and so guess what happened to Sarah
Palin she had a baby born with Down
Syndrome
that OB G1 should go to jail then that
would never happen again
but there's no consequences even for the
governor of Alaska even for the vice
presidential candidate the United States
her doctor screwed up that bad
and he didn't lose his license didn't
have his license suspended for three
seconds wasn't fined as much as a
traffic ticket
there's no consequence
this will happen over and over and over
and over all just went bad luck no
as bad or lack of advice
you wouldn't tolerate that kind of
service from anybody else from any other
industry
in the old days maybe burned at the
stake
the doctor would have been burned at the
stake in the old days
a couple more and then we'll get back on
the track here but these are too much
fun
oh here's the ones I've been looking for
the human brain as it's farming this is
a three weeks of age and this is when
homosexuality occurs at that three week
to four week level in here the
hypothalamus is farming and as the brain
is going down the assembly line to get
to this at six months of age it requires
a lot of stuff I'm one of the guys that
sued the FDA over folic acid without me
suing them
back in the 90s
they still wouldn't have folic acid and
prenatal vitamins there'd still be a
high risk of spina bifida I'm one of the
guys that suit them for that
okay
and so I'm very familiar with this kind
of stuff
cerebral palsy totally preventable
this is an underdevelopment of the
cerebellum the part of the brain that
deals with the fine motor movement and
you'll notice that people was
um
cerebral palsy is kind of a spectrum you
get them that are barely affected and it
takes a professional neurologist to tell
you that they got cerebral palsy I mean
they might just kind of walk funny and
you think God that kid's already dancing
but they already have some early stage
of cerebral palsy now in a child is born
a normal baby six seven eight pounds
there's cerebellum there's part of the
brain that affects fine motor movement
should be the size of a small tangerine
and they have cerebral palsy
that cerebellum could be the size of a
plum which is like 30 percent smaller
they're going to have cerebral palsy or
they could be size of a walnut which is
60 smaller they're going to have this
type of cerebral palsy oh he's got a
cerebral palsy kind of thing and then
you get this 11 year old girl who has
catastrophic cerebral palsy the only
thing she can move is her eyes
it costs a million dollars a month to
care for her
between all the physical therapy and the
speech therapy and this therapy and
feeding tubes and enemas because you
can't have a bowel movement all this
stuff
plus you know a hundred thousand dollar
machine says she can kind of with one
finger move herself around run over the
chickens because she can't steer it very
good and all that kind of stuff
this because
the mother was missing just a few
pennies worth of stuff before pregnancy
go to jail here this just goes on and on
and on and on
now her cerebellum you can actually look
the CAT scan size of a pea
her mother had severe deficiencies for
longer periods of time so that piece
went down through that 91 days and never
got enough to develop
and again for those who don't know the
anatomy
there's a cerebellum right here okay
this is this piece here that's a piece
that doesn't develop when you have
cerebral palsy varying degrees of
severity
is one of my favorite slides
everybody knows about belly button
herniases kids born with one the size of
a walnut you give them a hypnotic not
enough to put them under General antices
but just enough to make them kind of
drug-induced
intoxication you give them some local
anesthesia and 10 minutes time this is
easily dealt with
but here's another belly button hernia
this one probably mama was missing some
zinc for a week as the embryo goes from
a disc into a tube and this piece didn't
get zippered up during development well
here's one these two next two were on
the autopsy table these are I'm a
pathologist so I see crazy stuff like
this
this one there's no skin over the belly
button hernia and the stomach and the
spleen and some of the intestines were
hanging out
and of course it caused that childish
life it was a perfect baby perfect baby
nothing wrong with that baby except a
little belly button hernia
and the muscles incarcerated that that
um
circulation all that stuff
and the baby dies of circulatory shock
during the birth process
here's one that's really wild
same thing on the autopsy table here the
liver the stomach the spleen all the
intestines are out
that's a catastrophic belly button
hernia
totally avoidable
the OB-GYN didn't have his
license suspended for three seconds
didn't have to pay a parking ticket
gotta walk
now if a mechanic scratches your car
will you rotating the tires you sue them
oh this was just an act of God no it
wasn't
there's a failure of the system
same way here you can find a good
Christian doctor
who'd volunteer his time to sew up these
kids you can go to the save the children
fun to get the 250 each for the
anesthesia and the suture material but
all of this is totally preventable
rich women poor women middle class women
all have babies with cleft palate cleft
lip is a simple nutritional deficiency
the embryo when it's closing up as a
tube
how many of you heard of babies being
born deaf congenital deafness very
common it's a deficiency of a single
mineral manganese
I don't know there must be 200 studies
on this back in the 50s and 60s
we know for a fact as predictable is
gravity
you can prevent congenital
um a deafness and certain types of
things that would look like cerebral
palsy called congenital ataxia
because the semicircular canals in the
in the ears are all damaged from a lack
of one mineral manganese not magnesium
but manganese
there's a lot of prenatal vitamins don't
have manganese in them well here's what
the medical system is looking for
they're looking to decode the genes
there's a hundred papers that show very
clearly that this is caused by a
manganese deficiency in the first few
weeks of pregnancy they're looking for
the gene why because that's where the
Bucks are at
foreign
my favorites and we're going to take a
after they clear up all these terrorists
in Russia we're going there
beautiful little kids
this little village in Russia each year
50 of the kids there born
with 100 of this birth defect you'll
know what I mean in a second
25 percent are born with 25 of this
birth defect and the other 25 percent of
barn was a different type of variation
on this birth defect
the doctors there telling us it's a
genetics
caused by radiation from the power plant
700 miles away
Kaka you know that's a scientific word
Kaka
now most people look at these kids
they're so cute you don't really
always effective first
each of these kids is missing their left
forearm
that Village 50 every year
they're born with both forearms missing
25 are born with their left arm missing
25 with the right forearm missing the
genics don't work that way
now they're all born with a right
forearm missing
you could say Well it has the
possibility it has a look of genetics
but I guarantee it wouldn't be but you
know you could say that with this
variation it's not you just fourth grade
biology you know it's not you need to
spend millions of dollars trying to do
tests okay
and so in the near future maybe when I'm
100 years old we'll retire
and we'll go to Russia and we'll take
enough nutrients for all these sexually
active women who are in the child
bearing years and give them a year
supply of this stuff and that year there
will never be a baby born with that but
I guarantee you
the special nutrient called zinc is
missing in that soil
this is type of limb deformities are
caused by a zinc deficiency
somebody needs to go to jail
now you know
there's all of these
um
foreign
tests there's 850 of them these biotech
companies I mean there's a lot about
tech companies in California come up
with all these tests for genetic
diseases right there's a whole class of
people now called patience in Waiting
how many of you heard of patients in
waiting these are ones that are
diagnosed 10 15 20 30 40 years ago
diagnosed with one of these screening
tests is having this birth defect and
they were going to die within a year or
five years or develop the birth defect
here we go 40 years later and they don't
ever get it
this little girl does she look bored
even her dog looks bored
she's waiting
her parents won't let her do anything
because they were told that she had the
genetics for Cystic Fibrosis nap
didn't happen
one more and then we'll move on to the
stuff that you came to hear but I think
you as parents or grandparents you need
to hear this because when presents are
due given somebody a 50 Macy's gift card
is nice but it's not going to protect
your kids and grandkids from these types
of problems you better be giving them
the 90 essential nutrients
that'll be best you can do you'll add 25
to 50 Health years your life you'll
prevent all these birth defects you're
going to
aim on you because you can't unlearn
what you just learned tonight
okay this would be the last one because
you'll get the drift
if you're an eye doctor very successful
eye doctor very
you know he's an elder in the church and
all this kind of stuff and filled in for
the pastor good Christian man uh had a
family he volunteered his time for the
Lions Club and raised money for
eyeglasses and eye surgeries and those
kind of stuff and did the Rotary Club
and Etc et cetera Etc with his youngest
child
I reached 18 years of age
he went to Denver and he had plastic
surgery became a she
here
a pre-optic hypothalamus he knew that
when he was six years old but down here
he was a male
he was genetically a male but because
mama was missing something up here
he was a female
so when he had the surgery became a
female
had to go to federal court and be able
to play tennis in a in a world league as
a female
because he had the DNA of a male
but he won in court kind of interesting
stuff
kind of wild stuff makes you think
doesn't it
yes
exactly and I know
I know the guy who paid for him gave him
a grant to go to to uh
schools become an eye doctor
he's one of my he's a billionaire is one
of my patients
okay how many ever heard of AARP
okay
this is an issue their monthly bulletin
cover article March 2012 year and a half
ago
the worst place in America when you're
six is American Hospital
I'll show you why they say that I took
two things out of the article so you
know where they're coming from the
number of American patients who die each
year from American Hospital errors is
for the same as four jumbo jets crashing
each week I said there's 1500 people
there's three thousand every two weeks
is six thousand a month seventy two
thousand a year how many of you would
fly commercial airlines if you knew that
they killed the 72 000 passengers every
year nobody would fly
and yet you still go to a doctor
what do you think about it
they kill 72 000 of their customers
every year from just simple mistakes
hello they don't even get their license
suspended for three seconds nobody goes
to jail they don't get a parking ticket
people say well like why are you so
rough on doctors my wife is a micro
surgeon from Harvard for God's sakes why
am I so rough on doctors
well if they didn't give me the material
I couldn't do it could I
this is not my figures
Newsweek magazine cover article one word
that will save your life in a hospital
in America is a two-letter word that
every two-year-old knows no
you failed four rounds of chemotherapy
we have this new experimental
no
drug might live two weeks good send me
home
if you only have two weeks to live
wouldn't you rather be in your own home
with your own bed with your cat on your
lap or your grandkids hugging you you're
passing on your advice to them instead
of dying in the household being poisoned
by a bunch of money crazed doctors
mm-hmm
and it make better sense
and they say only have two weeks to live
say bye bye boys and girls I'm going
home so I can hug my grandkids instead
of your grandkid comes to see you in the
hospital they say honey you can't see
Grandma right now she's busy being
killed by the doctor
this is my favorite of all favorites
because they list the source of all
their information
this is a full page article in the USA
Today came out February 5th 2007 and the
the information was based on the basis
of the article the title self-evident
here patient Protect by itself
um and they said the sources and it came
from The Institute of medicine the
journal American Medical Association the
Center for Disease Control the federal
agency that tracks all this stuff I mean
we're talking extremely respectable
stuff the general American Medical
Association is the most reputable
medical journal in America maybe even
the world most highly respected I mean
even if you don't like doctors you got
to admit to that right
so that's where they got the information
from what they said was in this it was a
full page article I had to chop it up to
get it on here they said each year in
America each year in America each year
in America yearly American doctors kill
injured in fact 15 million customers are
workplace they kill injured in fact 15
million of their customers their
workplace
American doctors kill injured in fact
more people each year in America than
the mafia has in a thousand years
you're quiet because you get it
let's see
this was from Wednesday November 2012.
Johnson Johnson to pay 2.4 billion in
Hip implant suits this represents 10
million hip
um implant patients
insurance pay
as I say the worst possible thing for
human health in America was the
insurance system it causes this be
attractive to people the doctor says
well you don't fit that profile you'll
be fine okay
you die during surgery
or you get an infection they amputate
your leg at the hip
or the thing breaks apart in you they
have to go back in there and deal with
it
unless you get twenty thousand dollars
Yahoo
is another one of my favorites because
it deals with animals and people
remember I'm a veterinarian and a
physician
this one is from the Center for Disease
Control that Federal agency again that
tracks this kind of stuff CDC
remember I said earlier that according
to the general American Medical
Association the Center for Disease
Control each year in American medical
doctors kill injured and infect 15
million customers or workplace
infections in hospital this does not
include infections from private
practices and group practices and all
that kind of stuff just hospitals each
year according to the CDC medical
doctors infect 2 million people of which
ninety thousand die every year this is a
yearly figure ninety thousand die from
the infections inflicted upon their
customers in their workplace what would
happen to Taco Bell if they were to
infect and kill
90 000 customers they wouldn't be open
for three breaths
I mean they would be Gonzo
you think about it
you make sure you'll vote for somebody
because they'll vote you in Insurance
that'll pay the doctor can anybody name
an insurance policy
that prevents or cures disease
you see Insurance just pays a doctor
when you screw up
insurance doesn't protect you from
disease
it just offers you up on a plate to the
doctor
woof
well
how does that happen
how could that happen
well it happens because doctors wear the
same white coat the same trousers the
same pantyhose
the same shoes room to room to room
dragging peep poop blood pus not slime
bacteria virus fungus and yeast from
room to room to room
how can I say that
if I say something as outrageous it is
you know I can always back it up
because I spend so much time in federal
court attacking the FDA they would love
to get me so I'm always very careful
right
yes okay well
that was March of 1998
in August of 2012
17 years earlier
they identified one bacteria called C
diff clostrum difficile it's only found
in human poop it's a human poop bacteria
of those 90 000 people were killed each
year in hospitals
one third of them Thirty thirty percent
thirty thousand
are killed by this one bug human poop
bug
now what would happen if I ran or North
Korea were to send over an
intercontinental ballistic missile with
a biological weapon in it
hit the big
population centers like La Chicago
Dallas New York New York Philadelphia
Atlanta Miami
and it in fact
2 million in these high population
centers and killed ninety thousand when
we send those people a Christmas card
would we send those people chocolate to
win their hearts and Minds no even the
most Ardent anti-war protester would
fight you to be the one to push the
button to vaporize those people
because they just killed their grandma
and yet everybody wants to go to their
doctor because insurance pays
now to show you how bad this is
in 1993 there were 85
750 of these infections from C diff
calcium difficile human poop bacteria
17 years later in 2010 it went up 400
percent to 346 800. what does that tell
you
it tells you the doctors don't give a
rat's tail they don't care there's no
consequences it went up 400 percent
why should they wash your hands there's
no
consequences if they don't you know
Frank I killed seven people don't worry
about it don't worry about we're all in
the same boat just have another martini
and relax
see on the Green
see now if they were doing something to
stop all this
the chart should look like that
shouldn't it
but it looks like this what was the date
on this again this is August 2012. this
is not a hundred years ago
foreign
in 2013 it was a big article in in
The Wall Street Journal
there's never too awkward ask if you
wash your hands doc
you dirty Pig
get out of here I didn't see you wash
your hands
if you ever have to go to a doctor's
office carry a water gun full of urine
he comes in without washing his hand
just spray them
see how it feels Pig
that'll turn around a little bit
wouldn't it
here's one of my favorites this I go to
Canada a lot they get free medical care
why do they invite me to Canada because
just because it's free doesn't mean it's
good
Loreena McNeil
was the kind of on record most people
didn't know what she looked like but on
record she was kind of like the Dolly
Parton she was a country western singer
very very well loved and famous her
voice was just everybody loved her right
and she went into the cape Britain
District Hospital
where she lived it's a it's an island
Province a thousand miles east of New
York when it's noon in New York it's one
o'clock there I didn't even know it but
they have a separate time zone called
the Atlantic time zone never heard of it
there's noon in New York it's one
o'clock in the afternoon there
so I go there four times a year now I
get 5 000 people at my meetings in Cape
Britain they're getting free medical
care why they come to see me because
they're tired of being killed
so anyway
this is April 2013. she goes in for some
unnamed surgery whether it's breast
reduction or prolapse shooter she did
they didn't say what it was back surgery
knees or it didn't say she went in for
some surgery and three days later she
was dead from an infection with a C diff
icile
now the hospital the government Hospital
in Cape Britain
death rate the mortality rate was 37
percent above the national average
would he go to that hospital
because she didn't ask the Better
Business Bureau tell me about him this
is a volunteer you know this is elective
surgery it's not something I had to do
because I got hit by a card I'm bleeding
all over the place Collective surgery
she chose poorly didn't she she went
there and they killed her the most
famous women in Canada they killed her
because some doctor didn't wash his
hands after he pooped
yum yum
the Canadians saved me all this stuff
and they give me these slides when I go
there right so I can show to the rest of
people crazy
now the Chinese have figured out how to
solve the problem
I love the Chinese I'm married to
Chinese I love her I love the Chinese
they've been around thousands and
thousands of years before we even
thought of right
so here's how they have solved the
problem
now I'm not promoting this
but the Chinese are very practical after
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years let's say a farmer goes in because
he hurt his back lived in a big bale of
hay or something like that he goes in
into a Western Hospital instead of a
traditional Chinese medical guy who's
going to give them acupuncture and some
herbs right no traditional Chinese
medical doctor kills anybody they love
them right
remember they have 1.5 billion people we
have 300 million they have five times
the people we have it costs 50 cents a
month to treat each of their people
no deaths no infections
because 50 cents they've been known for
thousands of years 50 cents a month cost
you 1800 a month for insurance
cost him 50 cents a month
hello so anyway
let's say this farmer goes in and he
gets his back operated on he gets the
infection dies three days later or the
doctor plunges his knife too deep goes
through his disc and hits his arm he
believes to death and all that kind of
stuff you know there's all kinds of
reasons why people die when they go in
for a surgery
he dies well when all this guy's sons
and brothers hear this out in the Farms
they come into that hospital where their
picks and axes and shovels and rakes and
they beat that doctor to death all those
sharp instruments and tools
each year in China in the western type
Medical hospital setting uh it's um
27.3 doctors are killed by Family
relatives of people they've killed
so 40 of the doctors in last year have
quit and gone back to farming because
it's safer than being a doctor Western
Hospital
now you got to give the Chinese credit
now I'm not advocating this but I'm
going to show you how to stop the
problem
this is this will wind you up in jail it
won't really solve the problem
because a few doctors that still
practice will still practice the same
way right
so I'm going to show you how to solve
the problem
let me show you a few more of these and
then we'll get to the solutions
this came out in 2006 this is an annual
figure this isn't 100 Years of you know
collected information this is a yearly
figure that's my medication error Rising
now they're not talking about the side
effects of the drug here they're talking
about decimal point problems where the
doctor prescribed it wrong gave the dose
incorrect are the and are the
pharmacists fulfilled it incorrectly so
there's a three-year-old kid got a strep
throat the doctor writes a true
prescription for penicillin for the
strep throat and the pharmacist is
distracted for some reason and fills the
kids bottle puts the label on correctly
but fills the kids bottle with
chemotherapy tablets for a 300 pound guy
kills a kid well just tough luck
pharmacist doesn't go to jail doesn't
have his license suspended for three
seconds
fish is one of those bad breaks that
that little guy up there on Mars just
looked unkindly on you because you
didn't burn enough goats or something
well these types of mistakes and errors
in the United States each year amount to
1.5 million fatalities and permanent
injuries in America
why on Earth would you want drugs
because their free insurance pays
two dollar co-payment
hey I'm your
I'm here
's another one for the seniors
this came out in 2010 hospital care
failed for some patient so that's kind
of an out people go to the hospital and
die results in Medicare alarming that's
beginning to be alarming the study was
actually done by the U.S Department of
Health and Human Services office of
Inspector General which is essentially
the auditor for Medicare
this is a monthly figure and what he
said was every month every month in
America every month in America a medical
doctors kill 15 000 Medicare patients
over the age of of 65 who go in for
minor medical procedures and screening
tests
kill five thousand
how many apply commercial airlines if
you're over age 65 and you they killed
um 180 000 seniors every year
age 65. so you're out of your mind we're
going Greyhound
working great or Amtrak
so here's three very famous people the
doctors killed over the age of 65 in the
last three years
Andy Rooney
60 Minutes you know the guy that gave
these really cute stories at the end I
loved watching him
he retired in October of 2011 at age 92.
his wife was 87. they're going to go on
a world Cruise
and she says I'm a little nervous I'm 87
years old you're 92. the odds are in the
next year one of us is going to get sick
we're going to on this world cruise for
a year we're going to place we don't
even speak the languages we should get a
disc of our medical records he said yeah
this is probably a good idea so they go
to the doctor and well the office staff
is burning their disc for the records
the doctors flipping through his file
and said you know Andy you're 92 years
old here
and I don't see where we've ever done a
colonoscopic exam on you you could have
cancer lurking around in you and knowing
Andy he should have said you know I
don't have any blood in my stool I
haven't lost any weight my bowel habits
haven't changed the last two years
um I'm gonna wait for anything you want
to do to me until after the year goes by
uh but instead of saying no he said oh
okay
he goes in the next day the doctor puts
the garden hose up his rump punctures
his intestine
he dies in three days from peritonitis a
belly infection
she's an instant Widow he never went on
his Cruise doctor goes and plays golf
and has a martini
if you look up his obituary look it up
on the internet Andy Rooney's obituary
and he died
um in November 2011.
says Mr Rooney died from complications
of a minor medical procedure one minor
for him it killed him
another one of my favorites is Dick
Clark from American Bandstand
ages all goes in for his annual physical
tells his GP he's getting up five times
a night to take a p he said well you
know you might have diabetes you test
them no I said the odds are you having a
large prostate when I'm done with you
here I'm going to send you down to the
whole urologist and he'll examine sure
enough Urology games yeah you're getting
large prostate we're going to do the
surgery on you give you some drugs and
we'll eliminate that inconvenience of
getting up five times a night to take a
pee and he should have said no I said he
said okay
because the doctor convinced him this is
it's like clipping your fingernails we
do it's an outpatient thing you don't
have to stay a night in the hospital you
come in we get it done you come in at
nine o'clock it's done by 9 30 one
o'clock you're on the golf course really
yeah this is no nothing
okay instead of no comes in nine o'clock
9 30 is dead
why because when you cut on the prostate
gland it releases all kinds of chemicals
including prostaglandins which increase
your risk of thrombotic stroke coronary
thrombosis pulmonary embolism and he won
the lottery he got all three
died a half hour into the procedure
no they're wrong with him no none
but my favorite is this one this is my
all-time favorite
Neil Young our top astronaut first man
to walk on the moon personally saved two
doomeday the missions one he was on the
ground and the ship was going crazy and
he was able with a computer I mean you
have more apps on your cell phone than
they had those computers in those days
and he was able to save that ship and
save the crew then one time he was on
the ship and was going crazy they
couldn't control it from the ground so
he was able to with his knowledge of
computers to be able to save the ship
and the crew including himself
so he goes in for his 82nd birthday his
physical in a private Hospital in New
York
and they say boy
Neil that that NASA program must be
really something you're 80 years old you
got the body of a 50 year old all your
blood chemistry is perfectly normal the
only thing we can find on you is one
coronary artery has a three millimeter
wide 30 blockage way down at the tip not
something that's going to be a high risk
for
um thrombotic coronary you know it's
going to cause a heart attack and death
not in the right location to cause you
an angina moves higher up in the artery
it might cause angina but way down there
at the tip it's not going to cause
angina
and you know you're eight years old five
six eight ten years from now is a
progressive thing you get worse and fill
up that re and you could die on the way
to the hospital from a heart attack why
don't you let us do a bypass and and put
a stint in there and he should have said
no but instead he said yes sir let's do
it
goes in the next morning put him in the
head of the line
three days later he's dead was he dead
from complications of an elective
cardiovascular procedure it was elected
meaning didn't need to do it
I mean we had people I have billionaires
billionaires who don't want those
surgeries they come to me they have 98.5
blockage
in a couple months time they're 100 open
by angiograms by actual retests of an
angiogram because the doctors don't want
to believe it
these guys call me three or four times a
day I had one coming down here my wife
is a witness he called me okay
this happens all the time
okay let's talk about obesity the only
thing we can brag about being number one
in the world is we're the most obese
nation in the world we're number one
Yahoo
what does that tell you about the
medical Theory and the government Theory
what causes obesity I mean they've been
telling us the same thing for 75 to 100
years
eat too much you don't exercise enough
you eat too much you don't exercise
enough eat too much you don't exercise
enough now we're the fattest nation in
the world following their advice was to
tell you about that advice remember
Einstein he said insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and expecting a
different result hello
it's time to back off and say you know
doc I don't believe you anymore I've
been here 75 years my family's giving me
75 years we're all over weight we're all
obese and so we're going to try
something else
but instead insurance pays okay send me
the bariatric surgery we'll do gastric
bypass you'll put me on this drug and
this drug and this drug bam you're dead
because it didn't solve the basic
problem so what is the basic cause
I'm going to tell you what the basic I
don't care what they want to know but
you know now and you can save yourself
the people you love
foreign
of our kids according to experts under
the age of 12 are overweight 40 of our
kids on the age of 12 or obese 30 pounds
more of their ideal weight for their
height has nothing to do with eating too
much or lack of exercise nothing
that's all they talk all get thin for
early in January you know eat less
calories you can only do that for so
long that you start eating again the
weight comes back because you haven't
dealt with a basic problem
I actually have a book called Hell's
Kitchen which goes into that I think I
have a picture of it here but here's one
of the things we've already talked about
this kid's not going to make it to 25
he's already obese he's not even two
years old he's already obese
now these french fries are a straw man
they have nothing to do with obesity
nothing
now that kid lives to be 50.
these things will be the cause of
obstructive artery disease and his heart
and his brain his kidneys
but have nothing to do
oh thank you
have nothing to do with being obese
here's your first one I'm going to give
you three Clues and I'm going to tell
you what to do about it here's the first
clue here's a little girl here Natalie
hayhurst from Terre Haute Indiana was
famous I mean she was on Good Morning
America
back in
2011 because she was famous for eating
light bulbs that was her favorite snack
light bulbs I mean she'd unscrew them
from the lamp so she just crunched light
bulbs thank God there's no calories in
them
her favorite food her favorites she
preferred wood paper products cardboard
sticks she loved to eat rocks and dirt
she ate Diet Coke cans not classic Coke
cans Diet Coke cans hit the magnets out
of shower curtains and she loved to eat
plastic bottles and toys
that's probably why they took toys out
of the Happy Meal
because Natalie you know
so I called her parents because there's
only so many hay Hurst and Terre Haute
Indiana and I actually tried a true
story I tracked him down I said I know
the cause of her doing this
and I can help you
as she said and the mother said you know
we're going to be on Good Morning
America next week and I'm not touching
anything sorry goodbye
Fame was more important than saving that
kid
well this kid and you kind of said it
there's this kid has the same problem a
pregnant woman has now she's only three
years old the odds of her being pregnant
really low I don't need the examine her
although there's so many pedophiles who
become pediatricians they'd want to
examine her right to prove that she
wasn't pregnant
all right I'm going to perfect place for
a pedophile become a pediatrician
what about a serial killer what would be
the best job in your life as a serial
killer a hospice
everybody goes there to die so you kill
him an hour before they die you get your
jollies off because you got to kill them
Nurse Betty
you know exactly what I'm talking about
right
okay
so she has the same disease pika that a
pregnant woman has pregnant woman has
but she's not pregnant so what is it
that she has that they have well the
embryo steals nutrients from the mother
faster than she's taken them in and so
she develops all these cravings and and
binge eating and weird eating I mean who
eats pickles and ice cream they're
legendary who eats dog poop or the
tootsie rolls out of the kitty litter
box pregnant women eat weird stuff
I was in Brazil
in August of this year and they have
mostly Portuguese papers and magazines
and everything but they also have a few
English ones and while I was there this
story in English was in a Portuguese uh
Brazilian newspaper okay
this lady here 28 years old during her
pregnancy would eat 20 bass sponges a
day and even funnier she had 20 bath
sponges every day that people take baths
with but also she ate the sand
containing parrot poop from the bottom
of her parrot's cage every day
well there's a yummy thought
I mean this article if I were to write
in the article I just said poop poopy
doop
would have been the title right
and doctors send them a psychiatrist
they say just steal yourself and stop
eating that nasty stuff
now here's
your final clue
anybody here ever work with horses
okay what do you call it when a horse
chews on the fence
is what a baby stays in
one of you know yeah it's cribbing yeah
and horses it's called cribbing I was
there on just south of Portland Indiana
a couple years ago to see some kids with
mustard history which I tell some great
stories about that and the baby buggies
or the not the baby but the the horse
and Buggies were late and being a
veterinarian as well as a physician this
was a horse and buggy Amish farm so I go
into the barn and I didn't even need to
look at the horse or do any testing the
horse I could tell by the cribbing on
this rail inside the stall in that Barn
that the harsh living in that stall was
severely minerally deficient
now it's socially unacceptable for you
to eat your neighbor's Furniture when
you go visit them so they developed the
the custom when somebody comes over
particularly with little kids who would
kind of chew on the legs of Grandma's
chair
here have a cookie
so you wouldn't nibble on the chair
that's why they came up with a custom of
giving people somebody when you come to
visit them
cribbing in animals is munchies and
people when I bought my first Clinic
after graduating
naturopathic medical school in Portland
Oregon I bought a clinic it was a weight
loss clinic it was a 30 year old weight
loss clinic belonged to a do and I mean
this was a flourishing I mean I looked
at it they wouldn't show me the charts
but they did show me the after the tax
returns I mean this guy was making more
money than God I mean this guy was like
crazy making money so I said okay I'll
buy the practice for what you're asking
and then he showed me all the charts
when I signed all the papers and gave
his first payment
I noticed every month he's fulfilling
the same prescription of the same person
for thyroid giving the same person the
same drugs for appetite suppressant
writing prescriptions for them to go to
the same gyms and everything get it
taken off you know insurance would pay
for it and all that kind of stuff but as
people have been coming back there for
14 20 years they lose three pounds they
gain five they lose five and gain three
and you know their weights kind of
stayed the same for 20 years never
really happening but looking at the
charts it reminded me of horses that
were cribbing so I took 10 of the worst
patients have been coming to this guy
for 20 years and never really lost any
weight I gave him a mineral program and
in three days time they started losing
two pounds a day and in three months
time they lost 140 pounds each
that was in 1978.
so I've helped millions of people lose
weight
the myth about exercise this is actually
done loyal in the medical school in
Chicago I was published in January of
2009 this is August of 2009 cover
article in Time Magazine the myth about
exercise it won't make you lose weight
if all you do is exercise you keep
eating the same way you'll actually gain
weight
why because when you exercise you sweat
and sweat is not
just water sweat is a soup of all the
nutrients floating around so here you
are
somebody who loves you or your doctor
tells you'll be drinking plenty of water
when you're working out
and so you're sweating out the soup say
65 nutrients in it you're replacing with
water what's happened to your
nutritional Reserves
going down it reaches a certain point
where you're going to eat the bedpost
you're going to eat the rugs you're
going to eat the ashes out of the
fireplace you'll eat the coffee you'll
take a you know a screwdriver and take
the caulking off the wall
you'll eat drywall you eat really weird
are the tootsie rolls out of the killer
box
yum yum
so again
Hell's Kitchen the book this is actually
started as a sermon that I gave in the
church that I go to in in San Diego we
actually made a CD first called Hell's
Kitchen
and I asked the pastor I said well
Pastor since this was professionally
recorded in your church I have to ask
you is it for permission to use the
title I want to use for this because a
kitchen can be a bad place or good good
place depending what you're doing and I
want to call it Hell's Kitchen
he kind of got red a little bit and
stroked his chin thought for me said
well hell yeah
great Pastor because he knew exactly
what I was saying a kitchen can be a
place of hell you can kill everybody in
your family in the kitchen
you just fry everything you're giving
them clog their arteries give them Ms
give them Alzheimer's disease pour salad
dressing all over everything mmm there's
a lovely thought
but but it's healthy doctors say it's
healthy we better ask your doctor again
he's
56 and a half years old
the subtitle here Hell's Kitchen The
conspiration Cure of obesity nobody else
knows this except you and me now
she read the book
and then you throw in
ASAP
take the Healthy Start pack the 90
essential nutrients appropriate for your
body weight you're getting those
minerals which stop the cravings and
then to accelerate the weight loss
instead of a half a pound a week you
want a half a pound a day or two pounds
a day you take a dropper full of this
ASAP under your tongue within two or
three days you start losing a half a
pound of two pounds a day
I I get hundreds and hundreds of people
people every month who lose two pounds a
day it's not unusual for somebody who
needs to lose 200 pounds to lose 140
pounds in 90 days
very healthy because you're getting all
the essential nutrients
as long as they stay on those 90
essential nutrients for their body
weight they will never gain the weight
back the weight will never come back
because the basic root cause of being
overweight is being minimally deficient
in this book I have coming out this is a
big story in there
now how many have heard that exercise is
good for you no believe it or not how
many of your herd is good for if you
don't raise your hand you're a lion Kami
okay you've all heard it I know you've
all heard it Jim fix
during the 60s he was the darling in the
medical profession six foot four weighed
165 pounds these are actually a picture
of his legs
um he taught I think he taught economics
and in either Yale or Harvard one of the
um Ivy League schools out there in New
England and his thing was running he
said look
don't waste your time on vitamins and
minerals if you look in the index of the
book you're under vitamins minerals it
says go to page 165 you go to page 165.
it says don't waste your time taking
vitamins minerals just exercise
walk around the block 10 times you know
keep your arteries clean and you'll live
longer you won't waste your money on
vitamins minerals well at age 52 while
he was running and preparing for a
marathon he drops dead of a cardio mop
of the heart attack while he's running
at age 52 the theory didn't work for him
did it now cardamom of the heart attack
is due to a deficiency of a single
mineral
when Dr Milan and I did those 1700
autopsies 1 700 autopsy these kids in
China they all died of a cardiopathy
heart attack a deficiency of a single
mineral
well Jim fix his Protege his top student
was a Canadian
by the name of um Brian Maxwell and
Brian Maxwell ran 100 marathons never
came in less than fifth I mean that is
awesome 100 marathons ever came in less
than fifth you got to be kidding me he
had 114 gold medals three were in the
Olympics the other 11 were divided
between the triathlon the world games
Ironman competition this guy was
probably the most fit guy in modern
times right
other than Hercules and people like that
and uh his wife and his wife was a
nutritionist and dietitian they came up
with a concept of carving up the night
before a big event so you have plenty of
glycogen animal starch in your liver
your muscles that kind of stuff they
came up with that concept
this guy was no Novus when it came to
exercise the physiology of exercising
kind of stuff
also
um he and his wife came up with the
first power bar I may have heard of the
power bar power bar was the first
granola bar packaged and sold
commercially
it was so successful he had his picture
on the label Nestle paid him and his
wife 300 million dollars to the right to
that granola bar and they could have
come up with their own granola bar but
they wanted his because he was such a
famous athlete he gave him 300 million
dollars for it then three months later
he dies of a cardiopathy heart attack
while he's running
at age 51. now Jim fixed out of 52 he
beat his mentor by one year
I love this title here
says heart attack claims another Fitness
Guru
this obituary is in March of 2004 I was
actually up in Canada this occurred so I
this is where I got this article
probably didn't even show up down here
it's a big story because he's a Canadian
heart attack claims another Fitness Guru
well today he's not a guru he's just goo
and I'm a pathologist and a lot of times
when people get to you they're just goo
okay
thank you
okay now in America you hear of sudden
heart death and athletes all the time
kids
I remember talking about athletes of
every
sport
people who are cheerleaders and and kids
under 18 years old I mean they're
dropping like flies
10 12 16 20 years old while they're
playing they're just dropping down these
are kids who are fit I mean they've been
training for years just dropped dead
sometimes they'll finish their workout
take a shower go home and drop dead at
home
somebody needs to go to jail here
because our paper Dr Milan's my paper
came out in 1990 on 1700 autopsies and
kids under the age of 10 who died of
this disease
and that one doctor not one pediatrician
not one sports medicine doctor has hated
our work
published in an international chemistry
and medical journal
published in Chinese and English
this is not like it was a hidden thing
in Dell's comic books
three big universities were involved it
was published our kids are still done
because nobody has implemented
who he said to do now in China
by implementing
what we suggested they went from 13 kids
dying
per thousand every year of this disease
thirteen three thousand
down to one per thousand
that's huge
we do the same thing here
and all he had to do was take a good
multiple vitamin and it had this one
mineral selenium
has stopped all those sudden heart
deaths just like you flipped off a
switch
but our guys are smarter than that they
just say don't waste your time on
wallick's information just drink plenty
of water
and you'll be dead tomorrow I mean I
didn't mean to say that
but
I think plenty of water
now Jim fix died in September of 1982
and he was the darling of the medical
profession I mean they love this guy
because he was saying exercise don't
take vitamins and minerals I mean he was
the medical system's Ally
well in December of 1982 the journal
American Medical Association did kind of
a literature search on sudden heart of
death and they said after reviewing
everything they came out their little
article came out in Runner's World and
three months later in December of 1982
three months after Jim fix died in
September of 1982 December 1982 the
title was the exercise heart attack
Paradox now Paradox is something where
the outcome is different than the theory
now exercise supposed to be healthy for
your heart
but what they found out was
listening now remember this is from the
general American Medical Association the
editors the sports editors in there said
while running a man's risk of heart
attack death increases by a factor of
700 percent
so gentlemen
if your wife keeps asking you to go take
walks and exercise
is she taking out insurance on you that
means she has a boyfriend
ah
[Music]
here's another one that disturbs me
each in America
non-contact injuries to kids and others
are just running down the field and they
crumple because they tear a ligament
they tear a cartilage or a hamstring or
something like that it's not a impact
thing this is just
a one-man accident right they're just
running down the field cutting here and
there and they tear something
we're talking about 1.35 1 million 350
000 per year in America between the ages
of six and nineteen
somebody needs to go to jail here
where's all these Sports Medicine
doctors where's these personal trainers
where are the coaches where where's
everybody who's supposed to be taking
care of these kids
they're giving them Gatorade
well Gatorade has two nutrients in it
our sport shrink called rebound has a
hundred let's see if you're sweating out
65 70 nutrients
how much good is two going to do you
what about six Powerade has six gay Reed
has two our rebound thank you sir and we
have it in cans we have in these
canisters we have in sticks tear them
open put them in a glass of water or a
bottle of water
this has a hundred nutrients in it it
was designed for professional sports we
actually have many professional sports
teams basketball football hockey teams
use this stuff these are the sticks they
come 30 in a box thank you sir
and you know this is good when you're
doing whole big canisters or teams and
things just throw it in there
it's just really cool
it has selenium in it
nobody's going to die of a sudden heart
death they take rebound
are you getting a picture here
we built these things to take care of
your kids your grandkids don't let your
kids and grandkids die unnecessarily
because a sports medicine doctor
and the personal trainers and the
coaches have failed you but but they're
the professionals that doesn't mean
anything
it means nothing they've proven that
each year in America three almost four
hundred thousand kids in football almost
400 000 kids in basketball 172 000 in
soccer 119 000 in baseball softball is
58 000 volleyballs 43 000 wrestlings
forty thousand that was my sport uh
cheerleading cheerleading thirty seven
thousand almost thirty eight thousand
gymnastics is only 28 000 and track and
field is twenty four thousand almost
twenty five thousand he was just running
down the track boom your hamstring goes
because you don't have enough raw
material to maintain it kind of like
driving a car the NASCAR 200 miles an
hour without any oil in it you can
expect something catastrophic is going
to happen before the 500 miles is up
are you getting a picture here I think
you are because you're very quiet that
means you see what's going on here
so let's look at professional athletes I
mean we pay them millions of dollars in
event we're talking about the top guys
they get two three million five million
dollars an event
they only played for like three months
the rest of the year they're home
smoking cigars having a grand old time
travel around the world
so why do we have problems like this
because they're drinking Gator with two
nutrients powering with six water with
none
if you have somebody in your home who's
in the Peewee League Pop Warner League
who just exercised because they want to
stay fit because their doctor told them
to and they think it's good you better
be giving them rebound get them on the
90 essential nutrients and then you
won't lose them they won't become
disabled they won't get in trouble
physically
but you have to be obsessive about this
as my wife I'm crazy obsessive about
this our whole kitchen is all my bottles
of stuff every day I take my liquids
twice a day I take 75 tables pills and
capsules twice a day I don't expect
everybody to do that
but I can't get sick
I'm going on 75 years old I haven't been
sick in 66 years I have never been on
prescription medication you can't find a
75 year old who's never been on a
prescription medication
you and me babe even as a kid
even as a kid you never had any
penicillin or anything
okay good girl how old are you now
come on for science
not gonna give okay
39. there you go now listen she
well she she's not what's the guy's name
Jack Benny she's not Jack Benny come on
39 years old okay anyway these guys
drink water Gatorade Powerade
they just they're running down the court
and they just fall apart this isn't from
an impact with another player
okay look at this guy's got
I mean he's got all these bandages and
Ace bandages all this stuff all over his
legs these guys a mess
we look at the average lifespan
professional athletes depending on uh I
mean the average lifespan when you take
all professional sports combined is 62.
now these guys are paid to exercise
these guys are paid to be helpful these
guys are paid to exercise they're paid
to eat right to supplement right sleep
right do everything right stay away from
the bad stuff
and you think if anybody can live to be
100 to be professional athletes they're
getting paid to do everything perfect
lifespan of 62.
except for football players their
average lifespan is 51. yeah
51 yeah there's a big study it was done
in 2011 when they were looking at
changing blocking and tackling rules and
changing how helmets were made for head
and neck injuries and that concussion
all that kind of stuff
totally unnecessary
here's the one there's a Canadian
newspaper and they're doing a study with
Canadian football players and the U.S
NFL players and make a long story short
the sports medicine doctors were shocked
when they were collecting the
information for the study they said well
we can't believe that these guys are
average lifespan was 55 years of age it
doesn't even make 62 like we did the
total of athletes and so the insurance
companies went crazy wait a minute
we're losing money on these guys big
time when it comes to life insurance so
they got their actuaries their numbers
crunchers to look at this the actuaries
said
that's not a correct number
55 is not correct number the average
lifespan professional football players
is 51.
to Triple their life insurance premiums
so instead of 300 bucks a month it was
900 bucks a month of course you're
making a million dollars a game it
doesn't matter right
so you're still Ratliff
he's been with us for 14 years but he's
28 years old he had bone to bone
arthritis in both knees cartilage popped
off his right hip had to be surgically
re-implanted was kind of barely hanging
on they surgically replanted on he
caught a pasture regulation game broke
his wrist and the orthopedic surgeons
for the Atlanta Hawk said look this guy
is too fragile to play uh professional
basketball we're not going to sign off
on him so they killed his contract
he's actually in his locker clearing out
his locker and you heard one of our guys
Mike Glenn who had been a player I mean
this guy was an All-Star his nickname
was the Stinger a lot of his jump shot
records still are in play and he was
talking to another player about this and
so Theo said well that stuff helped my
joints he said yeah even yours Theo so
he got in contact and I put him on this
guy is six foot eleven and he looks
skinny but he's six foot eleven so he
weighs 300 pounds so he had to take
three of the healthy Bone and Joint
packs per month
and we invented the rebound for him 90
days later we had completely rebuilt him
he passed all his physicals they played
for 14 years
14 more years and made 140 million
dollars he was not going to make if he
listened to the orthopedic surgeons
now do you think his wife Christina
loves me
she loves me
she loves me she's six foot tall no
actually she's six foot five so every
time I go there she makes me a three
inch thick T-bone steak because she
knows he loves steaks me and Mary she
gets the top chef in Atlanta to fix it
for me and she just stands here on me
didn't pass me on the head and she's she
just loves me
foreign
report February 2005 special health
issue
rate in America's most credible print
news source special Health who needs
doctors your future physician might not
be a medical doctor who may be better
off
I guarantee that every medical doctor in
America canceled their subscription to
the U.S newsworld report every hospital
every Clinic every every Pharmacy
everybody who dealt with doctors
canceled that at least it wasn't going
to be out there in the waiting room
now why did they do that well this was
an apology to the American public this
whole issue is an apology to the medical
public because during the 1990s some
year old enough to remember the battle
between Dockers and the hmos
I'm the doctor I'm the one that's
supposed to determine what drugs you get
what treatment you get
when you get surgery not for your
illness do you want an accountant from
an H
Mo determining what you're going to get
and your answer should have been yep
because the accountant the only way the
HMO was going to make a profit was to
cure you in three weeks they didn't take
your 100 bucks every month for the rest
of your life
but everybody went with the doctors
including them
and once they realized
they looked at everything I just showed
you earlier they said oh we bet on the
wrong horse
and so this was their apology to the
General Public
remember I told you that my survey of
200 obituaries in in
I don't know about a five-year period
all from the early American Medical
Association was 58 well doctors didn't
like that so they ran their own they
said well while I Glide the average
general practitioner family practitioner
and primary care physician doesn't die
58 like he says we diet 56.
they're so eager to show that my my
results were imperfect that they didn't
care they showed that they died two
years earlier than I said so I always do
apologize for giving them too too many
years
yeah this is published in 1999 in every
medical journal in America
I don't know about the rest of the world
but in America this appeared
in 1999 okay
now this is beautiful this came out
December 17 2013. this was a big hoo-ha
I've been doing radio
for 20 years
up until about four years ago I had a
hundred and I think about 130 stations
well four years ago I got involved with
Genesis Communications Network
gcn
now I deal with 1300 stations
two hours a day
and so this message is going out
and when I read this story
that this was based on a letter to the
editor
my three doctors
who looked at a couple of
of articles
on studies that were paid for by Pfizer
Pharmaceuticals
they said
vitamins are a waste multivitamins are
useless
but when you look up the original study
the multivitamins only had three
vitamins
didn't have the 90 essential nutrients
didn't have 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential minerals and three essentially
they had three vitamins
and then they said in doctors over the
age of 65
it didn't help them with dementia well I
don't think anything could help a doctor
with dementia
because I guarantee they're all taking
statin drugs dementia is a physician
cause disease I'll get into that in a
minute dementia is a physician-caused
disease
everybody with Alzheimer's disease
everybody's passed your dementia
everybody of course called syndrome and
working syndrome was caused by a doctor
now prove that to you in a second I'll
be happy to go into a federal court and
guess who will prevail
okay so this was this is kind of crap
that goes on now why is this happening
well if you look at what's going on in
the stock market all these big
pharmaceutical companies are buying up
vitamin mineral companies like crazy
they're just buying them up like crazy
because why would they want you to cure
yourselves vitamins and minerals because
you'll stop using Pharmaceuticals
through buying up all these companies
and they would if I were to sell my
company to them which I'm not going to
do of course but if I were to do that
they would take see
to prevent you from having congestive
heart failure
or if you have congestive heart fear for
three years you've been on the heart
transplant list I'll get you off
medication in five days
I won't take you off your own doctor
will take you off the quickest has
happened is five days sometimes it takes
three months but usually five days or
three months you'll be off your
medication for congestive heart failure
because it's a deficiency of a single
vitamin it was discovered by a Japanese
Naval surgeon late 1700s
but why would a doctor want to cure you
for 300 bucks in office calls when he
can get 750 000 for a heart transplant
there's no law requiring him to cure you
when there's a cure available remember
there's self-policing Monopoly
they've killed off all their
competitions so nobody can offer you
a cheaper more effective safer option
are you beginning to get a picture here
time and efficiency is berry berry
congestive heart failure is a simple
vitamin B1 deficiency so our program for
congestive heart failure gives you 28
000 times the minimum daily requirement
five days time you're off all your
digitalis your height your water pills
your cardiologists and heart transplant
surgeon will throw up their hands and
take you off of everything take your
bracelet away from it'll light up you
know when they have your heart
I do this all the time
people say well if you can't do that
it's genetic
crapola
it's a simple vitamin deficiency
cardiometry heart disease is a simple
mineral deficiency a deficiency of
selenium
somebody needs to go to jail here
in any other industry I mean you think
about it Bernie Madoff defrauded his
investors by three billion dollars
and he went to jail for life
doctors defraud you every year in
America of three trillion dollars
not three billion three trillion dollars
do you love your doctor you send them
Christmas cards
because insurance pays
so I'm going to show you here how to
solve the problem I don't want you to
kill them
I want you to stop using them
this is my one of my last favorites here
on doctors and we'll get into the
diseases I'm going to show you how to
prevent reverse them nutrition
now remember I am into a doctor in 66
years of me being a patient I've autopsy
they decompose like everybody else
I've never been on a prescription drug
I have been sick in 66 years
I don't have any ailments I do not have
any ailments I don't have any problems
I have political problems but that
physical and physiological or disease
problems so
what if everybody in America were like
me medically
the medical system would be real humble
wouldn't they you go to your doctor only
once every 75 years
95 of all doctors would retire and go
into some other industry
you understand what I'm saying if you
take care of yourself you'll go to see
your doctor once every 75 years he won't
need them
I'm glad there's a few physicians in
here of various kinds because we're
recruiting them they're lining up to
join me
because they see the writing on the wall
I see one million patients an hour
while I'm here having fun with you guys
I'm seeing a million patients well how
am I doing that because I have a million
Pas how many Pas do you have
how many Pas you have
I have 1 million pas
okay I have a million pas
and each of them sees thousands of
people a day because each of them has
thousands of Pas you understand what I'm
saying
and I have cookie cutter recipes
they're all Betty Crocker recipes and
these books they're all Betty Crocker
recipes you just follow what the recipe
says the cake comes out the same every
time
start inventing your own stuff I take
your permit to work with me away
that makes sense
okay
New York time now my wife loved this guy
this guy was a cardiologist
he's a cardiologist he was a top soccer
player
in Brazil he was their Olympic star this
guy he kicked all his goals backwards
with his heels so his nickname was heel
of gold
he get a position he would kick the
goals backwards so I don't know why he
came up with that but as he kicked all
his goals with his heels so they called
him the heel of gold his nickname was
Socrates nobody even knows his real name
because all the soccer players in Brazil
take on a Persona nickname kind of thing
so his name was Socrates so he knew he
was probably a physician he was he's a
cardiologist and he drops dead playing
senior soccer at 57 years old of a heart
attack
my wife said oh he's so handsome yes
honey but he's dead
that's probably he's too beautiful he
should have been a girl he's so
beautiful
okay my wife and I took 10 years
to write this book immortality
because 80 million baby boomers come
along who all want to live to be 100
anybody in here born between 1946 and
64. okay three or four of you okay the
rest of your
older than Solomon probably okay
Methuselah I guess they say but we spent
10 years collecting all the information
from the National Geographic the New
England centenarian study newspapers
anthropology departments University the
agriculture department so we settle on
the top 20 longevity cultures that came
out of the National Geographics the top
21 longevity cultures they have 25
common threads
that allow them to be the loans for the
people on Earth okay they have 40 times
100 rules we do they have 40 times 140
times 100 we do according to the New
England centenarian study which is by
Harvard Medical School yeah 40 times 100
rules we do
they have 100 over 250 their population
we have 100 over 10 000.
they don't have any doctors they're all
illiterate
go from third world cultures not a
single first world culture in the top 20
longevity cultures
they have no insurance Governor private
they have no hospitals or clinics no
pharmacies or Pharmaceuticals or
pharmacists
great great grandma they have five
generations live in the same household
talk about conservation of assets One
Mortgage instead of five
grandma is a doctor with all the herbs
and you know her poultices and teas and
all that kind of stuff no need for
daycare because there's great great
grandma taking care of the kids and
grandkids and great great grandkids and
no need for hospitals because everybody
dies at home with everybody loving them
around them
send them off to heaven
and then
there's 20 other things that they do
they're a common they're all in this
book immortality everybody needs to read
this book if not for you
for somebody you love your kids your
grandkids your nieces and nephews your
brothers and sisters everybody needs to
read this book because this will add 25
to 50 healthier years to your life if
you're obsessive you can't just read and
say man that was cool and not implement
it you got to implement it I do I drive
people crazy when they travel with me
okay because I'm obsessive about this
stuff I don't expect that everybody will
do that
but my goal how many of you know that
story about Babe Ruth
and when the Yankees were down by three
runs ninth inning two outs and two
strikes against Babe Ruth how many of
you know that story
yeah Babe Ruth stepped out of the box
yep he stepped out of the batter's box
his cleats he points up the center field
for the flagpole was and everybody knew
what he meant everybody knew what he
meant including the pitcher he was going
to hit a grand slam home run that
pitcher was very stupid
instead of just throwing the ball in the
dirt and walking him and he could take
care of the other couple of guys he
tries to whiz it past Babe Ruth sure
enough boom he hits a
Grand Slam home run the Yankees win by
one run
so I'm playing Babe Ruth here and I'm
pointing out to center field
now I'm telling you I'm gonna live
beyond 200.
I'm Olivia on 200. now that's not as
outrageous as it sounds
because I'm doing everything perfect you
can standpoint of nutrition and
avoidance of the bad stuff
nobody's ever done that before I
probably have out of my 1 million
Physicians assistants I probably have 25
they're doing the same thing obsessively
as me I have some of them they're half
my weight you know these little old
ladies that are like 90 years old one of
them's named Char she's from Michigan
she's been with me for 25 years she was
95 pounds soaking wet she's actually in
this group's upline grand lady she takes
as much stuff as I do twice a day
she's 60 pounds lighter than me she
takes my dosage twice a day avoids all
the bad stuff
she just turned 70 in April if you were
to look at her you would think she's 40
years old
she has the physiology of a 20 year old
she has the looks of a 40 year old and
she chronologically is 70.
now I have about 25 people like that who
have been obsessive with me for 25 years
doing exactly as I'm doing
so let's look at some of these other
things that these people do
National geograph you got to trust them
they have no access to grind
well there's a story
this is one of the 12
or excuse me the top 20 cultures it's
one of the top 20 cultures that outlive
us these are the ones that have in the
Western Hemisphere they have more
hundred rolls than anybody else in the
Western Hemisphere
these are the clients from the decline
Peninsula on the Pacific coast of Costa
Rica and Central America
they said this little girl is going to
live to be 120 because a lot of them do
it's very simple they all do I shouldn't
say they all but most of them do these
kids are just living like crazy now
now they have no doctors no vaccinations
no insurance
they don't have anything that you would
go there this is the worst possible
place to go on Earth for medical care
there's none
40 times 100 rules we do it's a front
page story on National Geographic May of
2013. this isn't
may have
is 2013.
okay
why are they saying that because the
facts tell you this is going to be true
when you go there
and you look in the last two paragraphs
of this 10-page article because they
wind through everything
and you look at the last two paragraphs
they say you know this is a fact these
people do live this long these people
these kids will live to be 120 because
they do it all the time
the only thing we can't tell is if it's
genetic or dumb luck
it's absolutely dumb luck
a year
it's dumb luck
even an American can get the same
benefit
is dumb luck because sometimes thousands
of years ago when those people moved
into that area without knowing the
analysis of the soil
they have all the known mineral
nutrients necessary for long life in
that soil
and they refurbish it every day
I'm going to show you how they do that
they actually mentioned it in here they
didn't even know they mentioned it but
they mentioned it
[Music]
let's look at billionaires first
we actually have a CD we sent him a CD
called what kills billionaires hey Ryan
I love it because it sells a lot of our
CDs
what kills billionaires
billionaires are killed by the same
unglamorous things kill everybody else
hard attack stroke
polar embolism diabetes obesity
cancer suicide
this came out in 2004 as of 2004 there's
never been a billionaire lived to be a
hundred the average lifespan was 78 and
they didn't like that
so they asked Forbes Magazine to rerun
it which they did seven years later
seven years later Forbes Magazine re-ran
this study
and as of 2000
and 11 seven years later there's still
not been a billionaire lives to be 100
2011. still not been a billionaire lived
to be 100 the average uh or all the
other sort of stuff that they looked at
in 2004 were statistically the same
except one one was dramatically
different that was the average lifespan
instead of 78 like it was in 2004 the
average lifespan of 2011 was 66 60 it
dropped 12 years
now from a standpoint of statistic
that's impossible if they were doing
exactly the same thing
they're not going to drop 12 years in
average lifespan in a seven year period
it might drop 12 days or 12 hours they
might gain an hour a gain a month and
you know it's kind of like this it's not
a straight line in biology
what happened they knew that there had
to be I knew there had to be something
driving them they had to be doing
something that drove them to lose 12
years of average lifespan in a seven
year period what what happened
well I have a lot of billionaire friends
because I get the ones that are terminal
inoperable I save 95 of them so they'll
do a lot of what I ask them to do
because I charge them nothing they
always say okay well you have everything
you want and they think I'm going to ask
for a house in the Caribbean or
something and they would give it to me
but they never speak to me again so
their their long-term friendship is more
important to me than a house in the
Caribbean
so I always tell them I only want one
thing for me we'll call it even okay
well you can have it I want you to fire
your doctor they look at me say yeah
that's all I want from you fire your
doctor he's the one that said you're
inoperable he's the one that said you
were terminal and I saved you and all
I'm asking for is you to file the Doctor
Who is going to throw you under the bus
that makes sense so they fired their
doctors
I love it
so
I asked him to find out what these guys
do what the billionaires did over time
over that seven year period proactively
because they knew they had to be doing
something wrong
bad wrong
they came back a week later and said
well if it was very profound you're
exactly right
but these billionaires did
what these billionaires did
was kind of the top personal trainers
the top sports medicine doctors
and they spent over a half a million
dollars in their home their workplace
each in their home their workplace their
yachts and their vacation cabins up in
the mountains putting in fitness centers
because their personal trainer said you
know the reason why you're done so young
because you don't exercise enough look
at these third world country guys they
work out in the fields 10 hours a day
you exercise three hours a day instead
of nothing
they'll add 25 years of your life
so they were I mean they were rolling
they were running on the treadmills they
had their station everybody I mean they
are just running like crazy they said
drink plenty of water so they all got
Fiji Water
the most expensive water you can buy
they all got Fiji Water
guess what they just died by sweating
out all their nutrients and drinking
water they sweat themselves to death
well now they're all drinking rebound
here's a very very smart guy
Steve Jobs billionaire very smart
technology very smart marketing
he died 10 years before the average
billionaire he died of 56. why is that
well he was an unsupplemented vegan he
was a vegan who did not take vitamins
and minerals
and he believed because somebody told
him and convinced him he could save 50
people
each day by not eating cows because a
cow eats as much as 50 people so if he
didn't eat cows he would save 50 people
by not encouraging Farmers to grow more
cows so it'd be more food for people
that was kind of his reasoning for being
a vegan but then on supplementing he
spent a lot of money
for the top organic foods from all over
the world to be shipped in by plane for
him individually every day he hired the
top five star vegan Chef to cook
everything for him which he did is
stir-fried everything in salad dressings
everything and extra extra extra extra
extra extra extra extra extra extra
extra extra
virgin virgin virgin virgin virgin
virgin virgin olive oil and coconut oil
gave him pancreatic cancer just like he
shot him in the head
and then Steve Jobs made his second most
terrible mistake
instead of going to the decline
peninsula in Costa Rica in the Pacific
coast
of Central America is going and finding
the oldest great great great great great
great great grandma
saying Grandma give me what you eat give
me the herbs you would take if you had
bad cancer he'd still be alive today
instead he paid millions of dollars to
the top
experimental cancer doctor to delay
treating his other patients spend his
full time creating
the ultimate Panacea kind of like the
old days of The Alchemist
to cure his cancer and he killed Steve
Jobs as sure as he shot him in the head
this guy was a top
five star chef
what made him interesting was he only
did organic foods
and he was hired by queens and kings and
Emperors all over the world to cook for
them organic foods and he died at 54 but
caught him out of the heart attack
because you can have organic brussels
sprouts
do they require selenium no they can
roll themselves look beautiful with no
selenium in them
that at 54 the top
vegetarian vegan Chef in the world age
54.
or art linkler anybody remember art link
letter yeah okay 9
he ran into the book called Eisen a
couple years later he saw the black and
white movie Lost Horizon
which talked about the Huns of people
who live in the caracrum mountains
everybody thinks they live in the
himalayans but they live in the caracrum
mountains which separate China from
Pakistan Northern Pakistan
and there was also an obituary in the
New York Times of a herbalist
acupuncturist traditional Chinese
medical doctor by the name of Lee Eli
Chung Yu
and they the government of China
testified that he was 256 years old he
thought he was younger than that but the
government said he was 256.
and they had given him a certificate
after he was 100 years old but 150 the
game of super certificate when he's 200
years old he gave him a certificate was
250 the game of certificate and he died
six years later
everybody knew him and knew his face and
they said this is the guy
say and my wife even says she's from
Chinese oh it's a myth can't be right
but
if you read the book Rare Earth matures
you read the book rare Earth's men cares
talks about Rare Earth how many of you
heard of rare Earths okay Rare Earth
are used in electronics equipment
computer chips and cell phones and 99 of
all known sources
deposits Rare Earth on Earth or in China
now this guy grew up in Sichuan province
was born there lived there was an
herbalist there and died there
was his 24th wife he lived through 24
wives and he had no two of them at the
same time and one would die and he'd
marry another another one died and so on
okay
and this guy
lived in a place that's just rich with
these rare Earths you read this book
in chapter 11 it goes into all these
rare Earths they double the lifespan of
laboratory and let's say take a
laboratory rat or mouse or something
give them a relative Purina's nutrition
they'll live six years if so you give us
those pellets they'll lose six years you
had these Rare Earth to them they live
12 years
so maybe Lee Chong you was real
okay so that's what I'm banking on I'm
pointing out there now I'm taking my
Rare Earth every day like crazy because
I want to be the next Lee Chung you I
believe I can do it I have 25 people who
are going there with me do you want to
be there with me
the medical system will be real humble
I love that part
anyway he dies at 97. taking vitamins
minerals like crazy since he read that
obituary and look at the movies looked
read the book he supplemented like crazy
from the same sources they got their
supplements from which I'll show you in
a minute
this is crazy he lived to be 97 just
supplementing doctors lived at 56 taking
Pharmaceuticals
Wellness polling died at 93 and he began
taking vitamins minerals at age 18 his
first degree his Bachelor the science
was in agricultural chemistry which was
my minor it was an agricultural
chemistry my major is in animal
husbandry nutrition
he went to um
the agricultural school at Oregon State
in Eugene
got his first degree in agricultural
chemistry
he won the Nobel Prize in 1954.
and his Nobel Prize most people think it
was for vitamin C he never got any award
for vitamin C he was just kind of one of
his infatuations and hobby later in life
he never got any award for it in fact he
got a lot of flack from his peers and so
forth but he never got any award for
vitamin C
his first Nobel Prize was for studying
the nutrition of James remember I told
you earlier the genes require all these
cofactors and energy and substrate and
all they need raw materials you could
take for instance what he talked about
you could take the top Greek sculpture
this guy is 85 years old I mean this guy
has made some most gorgeous sculptors
any place this guy is a master at
sculpture he put him out in the middle
of a corn field in Nebraska say Okay
Master sculpture from Greece
I want a 72 ton 20-foot statue of Zeus I
can do that okay
come on
and he'll kind of look around he said
wait a minute I need a 75 ton block of
marble
I'm going to need some Hammers and
chisels and files
I'm gonna need some pulleys and all
kinds of stuff so I can raise myself up
and all these kind of things
and I'm going to eat a lot of food
because it's getting a lot of energy at
my age to do all this
and so this is what Linus Pauling
learned about jeans
no matter how perfect your jeans are
they can't do nothing without raw
materials cofactors and energy
and so he said in his acceptance speech
for his first Nobel Prize you can trace
every sickness every disease and every
ailment to a mineral deficiency
there's not a single genetically
transmitted disease out there
that is single one
what about Jacqueline anybody remember
Jack LaLanne
okay
when he was 12 years old he wanted to be
Mr America and Mr Universe and get those
two titles he accomplished both of those
by the time he's 25.
and he started his own environmental
company in fact Joe Weider just died
last this year too earlier this year Joe
Weider he had his own vinyl he died at
93 I haven't got his obituary yet
um
but Jack LaLanne taking vitamins middle
since he was 12 died at
96.
Doctor's Diet 56 according to their own
survey taking all their Pharmaceuticals
now I guarantee you his vitamins
minerals in 96 were not like mine mine
have all 90 appropriate for body weight
his head 38.
so even 38 is better than nothing
38 is better than the three those guys
who wrote the the letter to the editor
and said vitamins are worthless
38 is better than three well 90 is
better than 38. especially at 28 000
times the minimum data requirement
why would you take the minimum
well I'm only going to put two quarts
all in my car
even though the maintenance book says
six
I'm Gonna Save a few bucks here I'll
just put in two
people living under the bridge dumpster
diving behind McDonald's wouldn't do
that
this guy was just a recent story that at
95.
and he was on my program
for the last 20 years
we have distributors in Atlanta Georgia
including Andy young who is ambassador
to the UN he was the governor of I don't
know who's the governor mayor mayor of
Atlanta for three terms or something
like that
he was our ambassador to the U.N he was
sending Nelson Mandela for 20 years my
stuff
the healthy Bone and Joint pack the
rebound why do you do that because in
1991 Andy young was scheduled to have
both his knees replaced he had bone to
bone arthritis
Mike Glenn
introduced us
I got him on the healthy Bone and Joint
packs
proved his body weight in 90 days regrew
of the cartilage in his knees never had
to have any joint surgery
in 22 years
so he's been standing Nelson Mandela my
stuff buying Asher and sending the
Nelson Mandela for 20 years
that's why he lived the 95.
are you beginning to get a picture here
now here's my favorite obituary I love
this obituary
this is a great story
it tells everything
this guy here is the oldest man in
America when he died at 112. in December
of 2008.
12 George Francis and George Francis
lived through 19 U.S presidents
so the average lifespan of 75 if you
take out JFK
the University degree most of them if
they're lawyers will have two or three
they're cared for by medical doctors who
have two basically two they're pre-med
and their medical degrees some of them
have that they have Specialties they
might have a third degree or fourth
degree
if they go to jail they might have the
fifth degree
but the doctors who take care of these
presidents are not Country Bumpkin
doctors these are the best of the best
right
and they literally 56 exactly half a
charges age I mean I couldn't have paid
for this
well it makes this story so interesting
is George was an illiterate black fellow
living out in the swamps Louisiana
been to a doctor had no insurance
because he never had a paid job where he
had a paychecking with Holdings and any
medical benefits he made his living by
catching catfish and crawdads and
selling the Cajun restaurants in New
Orleans
had no utilities
and no insurance no doctors
the oldest man in America
what on Earth is going on here
well when he died the reporters are
smart enough to ask his daughter what
did your daddy do and this is her
reading the newspaper because he
literate he's illiterate
they got past sixth grade
he's a letter just a one school you know
one room school class kind of thing
so they asked her what did your daddy do
to live the 112 and she said he broke
all the rules of Health eating
who came up with the rules of healthy
medical doctors who lived be 56.
so he just did the opposite of what
medical doctors said
and she went on to say he broke all the
rules of healthy eating with a diet
heavy heavy heavy Dairy eggs and large
sandwiches
Dairy eggs and large sandwiches now
we're talking about cholesterol and
saturated fat here
the oldest man in America
never saw a doctor
couldn't read illiterate
the oldest man right now documented
by the Israel book records
if you look in the book rare has been
cures under longevity you look in the
book
immortality this tribe the Amira Indians
in Bolivia where this fella comes from
is in there the top 20 longevity
cultures on Earth usually number two
they've never quite hit number one but
they're constantly at number two
their Villages are 13 000 feet they
always adjacent to Lake Titicaca and
Bolivia
the oldest man in America excuse me in
the world the oldest man in the world
uh South America but in the world is an
Amara Indian he's a sheep her every
morning before Dawn he wakes up and
takes his flock of sheep up above where
he lives he lives at 13 000 feet
elevation he takes his sheep another
thousand feet up around fourteen
thousand feet there all day he heard
sheep seven days a week 12 hours a day
123 years old his name is Carmelo
Flores Lara oldest living person ever
documented
and in
October 2 of 2000
11.
they recognized he was going to be there
and this year they documented him again
as still the oldest living person no
doctors no Pharmaceuticals no insurance
nothing that you would go there for
health care I mean these are the by the
criminal people you can get they have
nothing
huh
no utilities he lives in a mud hut with
a thatched roof
he's still hurting sheep at 13 14 000
foot elevation at age 123. no cane no
Walker no electric wheelchair
remember I told you about genetics
the 850
biotech companies 850 Gene screening
things these guys need to know their
Anatomy a little bit he's got prostate
cancer in his left knee
she had asthma's right shoulder
celiac disease and right shoulder these
guys don't know anything right you
wonder they're having a problem
of course Eugenics like Francis Galton
and Hitler still hasn't change have all
these dating clubs
for people with IQ over a certain amount
kind of thing all the beautiful people
smart people
everybody else is we're going to spend
money on The Beautiful People the smart
people everybody else you're out right
and still eugenics
and here's what he said
sequencing is not the solution to curing
cancer and diabetes and all these other
diseases the solution is good chemistry
good biochemistry nutrition
they all sat there with their mouth open
not I mean nobody was breathing
the guy who got the Nobel Prize for it
said it's all been
irrelevant is the word he used
they went down the wrong
rabbit hole
it's not genetic
now all the reporters ran out of there
called the letter city well you you
can't believe what this guy just said so
these these editors are writing down the
story they're emailing them and all the
stuff they go to the medical schools
there and say we want your input on this
oh James Watson he's 80 years old
he doesn't know anything
he he's he's got dementia why would you
never appeared in any other newspaper
thank God my wife say this for me
this never appeared in any other
newspaper around the world
never appeared anywhere
but we're going to fix that
because this is a cover my new book
coming out in March of this year
it's already been picked up by a big
Publishing House a branch of Random
House big New York Publishing Company
the death of the genetic theory of
disease transmission
remember doctors thought disease were
caused by
evil spirits
and then they thought they could cure
diseases by finding a Panacea if they
could just turn lead into gold
and then they knew that they could
cure all diseases because they were
caused by what was called spontaneous
generation
that one that one lasted for a couple
thousand years and then there was The
Germ Theory oh everything is caused by
germs one million British and Japanese
Sailors died in a 100 year period from
scurvy after the basic sailor knew that
you could eat cabbage and and citrus
fruit and prevent it and cure it
one million British Sailors and Japanese
Sailors documented died in that hundred
year period from scurvy because doctors
were still looking for the germ
right after the Civil War there was a
string of what was called retardation
centers all down the East Coast across
this Old South
the Confederate States
the retardation centers were built by
the American government out of the
goodness of their hearts and your tax
money
to take care of people who had pellagra
because they knew that it was caused by
a germ and they wanted to isolate these
people just like they did for
tuberculosis so they built these
retardation centers with people that had
mental illnesses and from pellegra
which is a vitamin B3 deficiency it's a
nice efficiency
and for 150 years
they're pursuing the germ until one guy
went to an orphanage where all the kids
had pelagra you just gave them fresh
fruit and vegetable and cured in a
couple weeks
so you shouldn't be too surprised
that the graveyards are full of medical
theories that have been wrong
including the genetic theory
has been the biggest financial disaster
ever
so here we go now you know it's coming
in the contract
they're going to have more publicity
about this book than any other book out
there in history
why because they believe that this is
going to have the same impact on medical
science
has
Gregor Mendel and Charles Darwin
do you agree with the findings of Dr
Bruce Lipton I don't even know who Dr
Bruce Lipton is he must be some local
guy
failed
biology did he start the Tea Company
I don't know who Joseph Lipton is what
did he discover
he says that the the DNA is not genetic
well DNA is not genetic that's right but
I discovered it
I discovered that in 1977 when did he
say it yeah he stealed it he stole your
stuff he stole my stuff
now this picture is profound
this picture is taken in 1978
oh by the way the guy who wrote the
forward is Jeffrey Bland he was he was
Linus pauling's last PhD student he was
the director of the Pauling Institute
for eight years
this is not some schluck guy here right
he's a brilliant guy he and I've been
good friends for 35 years and I really
didn't expect him tried to forward this
because he said I could hear him say
well that's kind of controversial like I
want to see more before I put my so we
sent him a copy of the early manuscript
the titles subtitle
and he called me about two days later he
says I'm in I'll write the forward for
you
because over the years he's figured it
out too right
so anyway
this is profound because
in 1977 I discovered the first non-human
case of cystic fibrosis
in a monkey at Yorkie's Primary Center
at Emory University Atlanta Georgia not
a schlucky place I mean this is one of
the Pinnacles of Science in America
this was
looked at
by all the experts in cystic fibrosis
they said you know well like you're
correct this is the first non-human case
of cystic fibrosis no doubt about it
this is a classic case of cystic
fibrosis
nobody can deny this what we want to
know is how many other monkeys have this
well I did biopsies of age peers of this
monkey in a gang cage they're not
related any other way I deliver in
pancreatic biopsies and they all had
cystic fibrosis
well I tracked back the die to that
group and I figured it out I know by
then I already done like almost 30 000
autopsies
8 000 humans and 22
000 animals
10 million chemistries the book I wrote
in that is 1200 Pages it's in the
Smithsonian Institute as an actual
treasure
so this isn't just smoking pot and
coming up with a wild Theory
is based on 10 million chemistries
okay looking at nutrition and pollution
all that kind of stuff that's why
Jeffrey Bland likes me
because nobody else has ever done that
I'm not smarter than anybody else but
nobody has the experience
okay
and so
I'm going to divert here just a second
it's worth three or four slides for you
to see this
because this is all coming out this is a
major part of the book
here's the Emory University news release
1978. scientists at the Yorkies Primate
Research Center Emory University have
discovered cystic fibrosis in a young
rhesus monkey at autopsy the first
non-human case blah blah
this appears to be the first animal
model of cystic fibrosis we're all
excited about that's me Joel Wallach
right I'm the guy that made the
discovery
and these guys are like crazy with this
and then they fired me
they fired me
24 hours after I told him that I could I
could create a thousand baby monkeys
with cystic fibrosis in six months if
they wanted that we could have every
University study assistant guy bro says
and we'll have it we'll know exactly how
to prevent and cure it within weeks they
fired me said well you must be stiff and
good you must be smoking pot because
everybody knows this genetic
that's why I'm considered one of the
founders of epigenetics
that's why Jeff bland is so excited
about this book because it tells the
whole story Blow by blow detail by
detail every scuzz bag doctor involved
in getting me fired
because their genetic career was on the
line
they didn't care about the kids
they did not care about kids
they want to protect their little dung
Heap
at first this is what the newspaper said
because of that news release this
fibrosis finding his hailed
breakthrough reported in cystic fibrosis
fight
and then it went to theory on cystic
fibrosis
is disputed
so I went back to school and became a
physician
1978 and began as an advanced standing
student so in 1978 right after I was
fire began treating kids with cystic
fibrosis this little girl here Sydney
Myers was up for a double lung
transplant at two years old
got her going
reverse your genic markers oh by the way
this is the study that Dr Milan and I
did in China common denominators eat
algae and pathology visceral lesions of
cystic fibrosis and Keshawn disease
cardiomatically heart disease
China Keyshawn province
I should have this over here okay
there she is at eight years old
we have dozens of kids now that we
reverse our genetic markers positive
sweat tests so on
a little Italian kid
the hospitals this is a blind study not
a double blind so anybody blind study
because we're giving them this stuff and
the hospitals don't know it they're
testing them every couple of months they
go positive positive positive positive
negative what what's going on here
whether they suddenly go negative they
were on a stuff for 30 days when they're
just
less than a year old in two weeks they
convert back to normal and they're three
years old it takes them two three four
weeks they're 10 years old it takes them
four to six months when they're 25 years
old it takes them a year but they go
back to normal
now in 2011 in the in the international
laboratory animal research Journal
the entire journal in June of 2011 was
devoted to serendipitous accidental
findings involving non-human primates
the reason why they did that was because
in 2011 the federal government canceled
all research and primates because too
expensive a thousand bucks a day
compared to a mouse is 10 cents a day so
you use mice if you want to use primates
go to Bill Gates Foundation go to Warren
Buffett don't come to us so they did
this whole issue on The Accidental
findings in primates that helped human
health to say please reconsider you know
don't kill I mean we got billions of
dollars worth of facilities here's and
monkeys what do we do we're going to
kill them all I mean come on we can't
just suddenly stop here so give us 10
years 20 years that's they're trying to
soften the blow here
foreign
well you might guess you probably
guessed that they gave five top stories
and accidental findings and primates
that benefited human health
guess what number two was
cystic fibrosis is a non-human primate
Emory University in 1978 reported a
classic textbook case of cystic fibrosis
found in humans had been identified in a
non-human primate an animal from which
there has not been described previously
an assistant battery pathologist
me
actually has more than that as a
comparative pathologist they're doing
human and animal attacks but they call
me an assistant very pathologist I mean
now here it comes now be prepared for
this
let's see here
oh we're down here uh
the diagnosis oh there we go an
assistant very pathologist whose name
was withheld by Emory University they
were so embarrassed that they fired me
in 1978 they wouldn't even give out my
name now are they that stupid
if they say oh gosh this was identified
in 1978 well that's easy they just go
back to 1978 find the news releases
so I started winning all these kind of
medals based on the stuff that went on
in 1978.
now millions of kids have died
since then
and they're still going to die
because they never said well there was a
failed Theory or whatever you know they
said nothing
they just said one was found
somebody needs to go to jail
well
here's a result of that study and here's
why I'm considered one of the founders
of epigenetics
up until
this
award
2011.
I'm the first veterinarian in the first
naturopathic physician to get this award
for 28 years in a row only medical
doctors and MD phds got the award
on the first veterinarian in the first
naturopathic doctor to get the award
and of course I just loved it that they
used the Emory University photograph
you gotta love it right to show that
this discovery been made by this
assistant pathologist who nobody named
that really pissed these people off okay
they could have they could have
kind of rectified or at least gotten
some sympathy from me if it had said
okay we found this guy was stupid on our
part but our guys those guys are all
dead are gone blow
so this is Dr shrauser
warning me
the
gold medal the cloud Schwartz now why
the cloud Schwarz metal because clown
Schwartz is the guy who discovered that
selenium is an essential nutrient
Hua
I'm very very proud of that
okay now we're going to talk mustard
history
have you heard of Jerry Lewis Telethon
well Jerry Lewis hasn't done the
Telethon for the last three years
because of me it was it was an
unintended consequence we gave him five
years of studies on mushrooms because
we're curing
reverse all their genetic markers again
when they're three years old a couple of
weeks they can lay there like a worm and
two three weeks syrup playing soccer
all their genetic markers your blood
tests everything's normal biopsies are
normal
we gave all this we gave a pile like
this to Jerry Lewis on I don't know
maybe a hundred cases there the doctors
call them cured not me
they don't know why but they don't have
it anymore
all their charts so we gave them copies
of that we gave them email copies hard
copies
and say Jerry we don't want any money
from the mustard Foundation we don't we
don't need to do any research we already
know the Cure we know the cause
prevention cure much history
all we want to know is these are Jerry's
kids do you want to be the one to make
the announcement to thank God the Cure
has been found
finally would you like to be the one to
make it he says well yeah and so he
takes all this to the medical committee
the mustard issue Foundation said look
this guy Wally can send these in I I
don't know much about this but I read it
and it looks like they're negative now
they were positive before they said
Wallach Wallach and they looked me up
and they said well he's the guy that
said cystic fibrosis 1978 could be
prevented cured not genetic this guy's a
nut we're not going to even waste our
time reading his material
Andreas Lewis said quote you know I've
helped you guys for 22 years I help you
raise over a billion dollars in 22 years
I've never asked for anything for myself
I really would like you to read this
stuff and you tell me then that it's
useless then I'll feel at least we've
done our best and we've looked at it and
maybe his claims are nuts but at least
we didn't miss a chance to examine every
stone right we look under every stone
but if you tell me you're not going to
even look at it I'm I'm really going to
be offended here
and they fired Jerry Lewis they fired
Jerry Lewis
whoa
that's why he has another Telethon he
hasn't spoken about it because he has a
contract with him non-disclosure can't
work with anybody else for 10 years
after they part all that kind of stuff
so we're having our first Telethon
in February
non-profit and organizations already
existed called defying muscular dispute
defying mustard
d-e-f-y-i ing defying mustard industry
defying MD is another way.com
and
this organization has already we chose
to be associated with them because they
have
um their non-profit status but they
already have an FDA approved
study that they did and published
so we know and so we say okay our goal
is to raise 10 million dollars what
we're going to do we're not going to
take any of it all the costs are
thinking about we're going to cover
ourselves we're not going to say 100 of
us going to the kids we're going to do
is take these families that are out of
their own pocket bought all the
supplements did the diets just exactly
as we said gave us the records we're
going to reimburse them
for their expenditure for their
supplements for the one year that's
going to do with the money we only get a
hundred thousand dollars we'll equal it
up and divide it up but our goal is is
um 10 million dollars which will then
give everybody their money back that are
involved
we're not going to take a single penny
from it
and so this Telethon you want to watch
for it is coming out February 21st and
22nd
and if you're thinking about donating
anything this year go look on defining
mushroomsv.com
go look at it because they have films
every two weeks of all these kids that
have started the program
every two and you can see the progress
kids who couldn't even raise their arms
are now riding tricycles and ringing the
bells and it's just amazing every two
weeks they have another film in these
people
and so if you have in your hearts to
give a little donation I don't care if
it's 10 bucks anything
to be very sweet okay this organization
was started by this guy here Todd
Harrison
just turned 25 a week ago this picture
was taken a year ago and he's been on
our program for over a year
and here's the guy who's been in a
wheelchair for eight years and now he's
you couldn't tell me anything wrong with
you just look at his look at his films
every two weeks
okay so he goes back again why isn't
Jerry Lewis doing the Telethon because
they fired him they don't care about the
kids either they didn't want their
income stream interrupted
they're taking 80 of any way for our
administrative cost
shame on them shame on them
absolutely Criminal okay so now you know
why we're passionate about this
um why did I start this company
is because I need an army to get the
information out
okay now I'm going to spend just another
10-15 minutes and I'll be done we'll
open up for questions and you give some
announcements all this kind of stuff
and this is the basic problem
this is from food chemistry
April 2012 and food chemistry is a very
boring but very well respected Journal
they send graduate students out to the
fields they harvest carrots and beets
and corn and wheat and tomatoes and all
kinds of stuff and they run tests on
them for pollution and nutrition they
publish every month The Heading is
carrots and they have all the fields
that came from what state and they came
what county and the all the analysis and
only scientists would really appreciate
the value of that
but I read it every month because I'm
interested in pollution because I've
found the first
case of mass die off in America from
pollution when I was doing all those
autopsies for the Center for Disease
Control
anyway April 16 2012 they looked at
eight commercial baby foods Similac
Enfamil
um things like Gerber so it's a very
well respected baby foods they said
commercial available baby foods may
contain less than 20 percent of the
recommended levels of minerals and
vitamins
less than 20 dog food has 100 chicken
food has 100 laboratory rat food has 100
your babies your grandbabies have less
than 20 percent
how do you make up the difference you're
going to go to the doctor and say hey
please please can I have permission to
give my baby a supplement
don't even waste your fuel to get there
don't waste your telephone bill to lift
up the telephone and call them don't
embarrass yourself
the reason why it's this way is because
the pediatricians who came up with these
formulas had no training in nutrition
it's absolutely downright criminal you
would not tolerate this in any other
industry
okay so why do things look generational
I mean that's an obvious question why do
things look generational well I have
five generations in my family with
diabetes you're telling me that it's not
genetic it's obvious as genetic because
I have five generations
well here it is folks
have you ever heard of gluten
intolerance
okay gluten intolerance doesn't mean
you're allergic to wheat a lot of
doctors will test you for wheat I would
say well you're not allergic to wheat go
ahead and eat all the wheat you want bam
you're dead
gluten intolerance is kind of like
poison ivy I get here and I just met
most of you I guarantee you that none of
you in this room is allergic to poison
ivy because you don't eat it for salad
there's no pollen associated with it so
nobody's allergic to poison ivy but I
guarantee you're all intolerant of it
nobody would voluntarily without a lot
of money being offered to them drop
their pants and let me take some nice
fresh juicy poison ivy rub it all over
your bottom
because you get contact dermatitis
wouldn't you it'd be bad it'd be really
bad okay
you would not like the result
the same way when you eat gluten and you
have a gluten intolerance
you're not allergic to wheat but you're
going to get a contact enteritis and
enteritis and inflammation intestine
some doctors are called leaky gut
syndrome because when they test you
they'll test what you put in here and it
all comes out the other end they say
well you got leaky gut because they're
assuming they're little p brains are
absorbing it
you're not absorbing it you're never
absorbing at all you are not what you
eat that'll add as you are which heat
that's absolutely positively not true
you're not what you eat not what you
absorb
and when you're gluten intolerant what
happens is those little finger-like
Villi that help move the food along
also they increase your absorption
Surface by 85 percent
but hems is when you're gluten and
tolerant they go away over a period of
months and years they just go away and
suddenly now your intestines are just a
smooth tube like a garden hose you lose
all those villi
some of the classic symptoms of a basic
gluten tolerance or eczema dermatitis
psoriasis rosacea asthma chronic
bronchitis
and then you wind up with 20 30
different diseases over the years as
time goes along you can't even if you're
supplementing you can't absorb the stuff
wind up with all these diseases
this is a cut article in the New York
Times Sunday magazine
February 4th 2013. why is that the title
was eat no wheat the cover picture was a
guy in a hazmat suit holding a slice of
organic whole wheat bread
now while these diseases are not
genetically transmitted gluten
intolerance is transmitted by cord blood
and breast milk
some of my worst nightmares is dealing
with women who love their breasts I Am
Woman I have breasts I have all this
milk but my baby
is one of these colicky babies and can't
tolerate my milk so I'm going to save
the world I'm going to donate my milk to
the lychee League and they give somebody
else's baby a gluten intolerance
you see human breast milk is not perfect
food for many people
if you're gluten intolerant it is not
perfect food
I get them on the radio they call me all
the time I have an autoimmune disease
well tell me about it yeah I've been to
27 doctors over the last 14 years I also
have autoimmune disease every year I get
a new disease I have 22 disease now I'm
on 27 prescription drugs I have all
these problems they've opened me up and
operated on me and taken this out and
taken that out and and they're prepared
to do it again because nobody can figure
out what I got they see did you have
your appendix out yeah
if you have asthma's kid well yeah I
still have it any skin problems yeah I
got rosacea
we have gluten intolerance did anybody
doctor ever tell you that no but I was
here I was diagnosed with irritable
bowel syndrome
for more than 20 years not a single
doctor if they knew it said anything
about it I just think they're ignorant
they didn't even know it
but they should all go to jail because
ignorance of the law
is not a defense is it
back and say you know we've been
treating Crohn's disease the same way
for 70 years it all winds up the same
way in disaster
maybe we should re-look this thing
you see there's no competition
what's the odds of finding the right
information if everybody knows the Earth
is flat
a couple more here
we do have go Foods we just bought this
company this year
they're all organic no trans fatty acids
or hydrogenones no MSG no pesticides
herbicides non-GMO 50 of the 25 Foods we
have are gluten and lactose free and
they're they're 25-year shelf life
we just had an entire boat load to the
Philippines we just gave it to them
okay our distributor is all chipped in
we sent I don't know how many
100 tons of this stuff but literally 100
tons of this food over there for those
people they were glad to have it
okay here's the bottom line folks
five or six more slides were done
why do we call ourselves 90 for life
because there's 90 essential nutrients
60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential
amino acid three essential fatty acids
how long do you need them for Life Just
Like Oxygen how long you need oxygen for
Life how long you need water for life
okay I need the 90 essential nutrients
this is all based on people so you got
research on that well it's all based on
trillions of dollars worth of research
over the last hundred years
to agricultural schools
do the U.S department of Agriculture
Veterinary Schools count of course they
do they gosh well that's just an animals
has been proven in humans we're prepared
to kill you until it's proven to humans
well they they test drugs and animals
don't think they use them
so that's kind of a weak excuse
90 essential nutrients why they call
them essential nutrients for two reasons
number one you can't make them you've
got to consume them every day there's
food or supplements number two
if they're missing for any length of
time you get horrible diseases all of
which are fatal some of them put a total
potassium deficiency you'll die of heart
stop each within a few seconds
Calcium deficiency causes 147 different
diseases all of which will kill you but
it might take 40 years to kill you for
the Calcium deficiency
every medical and dental specialty loves
calcium deficiencies because they all
make most of their money from a Calcium
deficiency
60 minerals you notice two-thirds of the
90 essential nutrients or minerals
that's why we focus a lot on them 16
vitamins 12 centimetal acids three
essential fatty acids
this I love this this is a cover on a
weekend magazine in the um
Globe and Mail which is sort of the
Canadian equivalent of the USA Today the
bottom of this cover article was this
and the top was this they said what
you're going to choose pills or produce
now can you tell me how much vitamin C
is in that that tomato
you can tell me how much folic acid is
in that green bell pepper if you tell me
how many milligrams of calcium are in
that apple
no
are you willing
to throw your kids and grandkids or your
spouse your brothers and sisters your
mama under the bus
assuming that there's everything you
need in that food
for supposed to be the Pinnacle
of God's creations that's pretty stupid
on the other hand you can take any one
of these and look on the bottle they
came in how many milligrams of calcium
how many micrograms of B12 and so forth
are in there
so why don't you do both that's what I
do I do both
I like to eat well I eat very very good
food my wife is a great cook and we have
a lot of fun eating we eat good food
but we also are obsessive about this
part we don't care what's in or not in
the food I don't care I don't need it
when you look at a label on the back of
a can of dog food that doesn't reflect
what's in the food that's what we put in
the food
if we were to analyze every batch of dog
food
and say okay we need to put three more
milligrams of this in here to make it
right and 20 more milligrams of that in
there it costs you 500 was a can of dog
food so we just put everything we know
they need in there that's what's on the
label we have no earthly idea which we
screen it for pollution and poisons
we don't analyze it for nutrition we
just put everything we know they need in
there and anything that's in there
nutritionally is value added
you go to bed every night saying I ate
well I had four different colors on my
food plate
I ate variety every day
and I know I'm going to make it to a
hundred and you die at 67 while you're
jogging
drinking water
this is a very profound article
and all I had to do is trim this up a
little bit to get it on this page it's
just a great great article
now where did rich people get their
supplements a thousand years ago two
thousand years ago
mummy dust
there's actually a business where the
grave robbers would grind up mummies
particularly of Royal mummies and sell
it in bags of those mummy dust as a
supplement now think about it they had
bone meal in there they had hyaluronic
acid from the cartilage and the tendons
they had B12 and selenium in the liver
mummy dust was a pretty good supplement
if you think about it but I mean only
rich people could get mummy dust
I ate my mummy
okay is that cool there's a whole
section in this new book coming out
about mummy doesn't and now the season
Mommy does all the stuff all the the
whole business of mummy does I mean went
on for hundreds of years
after a while when they ran out of real
mummies they go and kill poor people and
dehydrate them in the desert and chop
them up and grind them up and sell them
for mummy dust because there's too much
money in it to give it up right doctors
are very creative
well here's where the poor people got
their minerals so be prepared are you
prepared for this
I hope you remember going to your
parents house your grandparents house in
a wood stove
okay what did they do with the wood ash
there morning they put them in the
recycling bin to save the Earth where
the wood ashes go and the garden went in
the garden now what ashes are not ashes
in the old days everything that was
burned had some kind of white or gray or
brown or beige powder they call them
ashes ashes ashes dust to dust kind of
stuff
and but really when you analyze those
wood ashes are really the minerals that
the tree sucked up out of the ground now
what ashes are all not not all alike
because nutritional minerals do not
occur in a uniform blank around the
Cozier they occur in veins like
chocolate and chocolate ice cream some
wood ashes some plant minerals from a
tree have three minerals in it some have
ten some have 24 some have 40 some have
60. kind of like in the nikoian
peninsula
in the Bolivian Village the Amara people
like
Laura 223 years old
Dr Lee Chung Yu 256.
did burn wood take those plant minerals
AKA wood ashes roaming the garden and
eat the tomatoes the squash and the okra
and the sweet potatoes and the onions
and the corn whatever it was and they're
getting
they're getting their
their mineral supplements through the
food that they've supplemented and
eating the food they didn't get their
mineral supplements through capsules
but they got them mineral supplements
through the food that they supplemented
with these minerals
so here it comes here's the bottom line
and then we'll end it
the bottom line is this folks
at three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 it all ended we know
the exact moment because this story was
in the front page
it was on the front page of every
newspaper
in the world
because on the front page of every
newspaper in the world this story came
out
Monday September 4th at three o'clock in
the afternoon 1882. it all ended after
thousands and thousands and thousands
and thousands and thousands of years of
people supplementing with minerals
through wood ashes
it all ended in one heartbeat
it ended when this when this guy here
says and pulled the switch on the first
commercial electric generating plant on
Pearl Street in New York City on the
bluff overlooking the construction of
the Brooklyn Bridge
here comes the ultimate question
that minerals how many wood ashes are
left over when you fuel your home the
electricity propane Natural Gas
zero NADA Zippo nothing
here comes the other ultimate question
what did you replace
as source and mineral supplements with
the humans have done for thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands
and thousands of years nothing
that's why you're getting sicker because
every time you harvest a crop it pulls a
little bit of minerals out of the soil
if you're not replacing it
you harvest another crop it keeps
pulling minerals out of the soil and
after a while you got to dust bowl
because there's no more minerals left in
the soil nothing will grow without
putting some
Miracle Grow in there or something but
that's only three nutrients mpk
what about the other
87.
we're beginning to get the picture here
so this guy unwittingly
unintended consequences
killed America
health-wise
here
I guess I got two more slides I
apologize
because it makes us unique there's a
compost pile it has 77 certified organic
plant minerals in it these guys are
standing on a road the 3000 foot
elevation above sea level this Camp up
here is 25 foot thick Marine Limestone
we know that because the animal plant
fossils are marine animal and plant
fossils came from the sea so this
compost is these plants is 100 plants
you take a handful of it looks like
coffee grounds look out of the
microscope you sell the plant cells and
little veins and everything and plants
like leaves and things
we've been under the sea for thousands
and thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years
it's totally pollution free I mean there
is no pollution in there
has all 60 essential minerals and
optimal amounts and this is a core of
everything we do
we have 25 different ways to get the 90
Central nutrients we have a thousand
products
my favorite to get the 90th Century
which is a Healthy Start pack you heard
me talk about this several times today
this is designed for 100 pounds of human
flesh or amongst for perfect nutrition
perfect biochemical nutrition I take two
of these a day
plus all my other supplements to avoid
all the other health problems I don't
wait until they happen I just take
everything like I was getting you know
trying to cure it so I don't get it
it's called preventive maintenance right
well this is good for 100 pounds of
human pleasure amounts if you give this
to a 50 pound kid or 50 pound Spanish
[__] who's four foot tall and 40 years
of age it doesn't matter if they're 50
pounds this will last them two months it
goes to 100 pound person you ever take
10 pounds and last a month you give it
to a 200 pound person last two weeks he
was a 300 pound person last 10 days if
you're giving it optimally for body
weight
then we went one step farther and this
is the last slide
premature
I'm not a politician
okay
this is a Healthy Start pack I just
showed you for 100 pounds of human flesh
for a month
if you have diabetes or any blood sugar
problem you take the healthy blood sugar
pack you take one of these per 100
pounds of body weight per month
you check your passing blusher every
morning before you medicate yourself and
as your blood sugar is dropping your A1C
it will go hemoglobin is coming down you
can reduce your medication just like
your doctor taught you to do usually
within two to four weeks you lean on
your medication you're an ex-diabetic
people say you can't do that that's
genetically transmitted oh you have
aluminum power so if you have five
generations of your family with it
it's not genetically transmitted and
then
healthy Bone and Joint pack if you have
arthritis lupus tendonitis degenerative
disc disease peripheral neuropathies
anything to do with bones and joints and
discs and cartilage and ligaments and
tendons and muscles one healthy bone
joint pack for 100 pounds of body weight
healthy digestion packet they have
reflux there is no such thing as acid
reflux anybody who says it has a reflux
should be put in jail anybody who pushed
on proton pump inhibitor should be put
in jail
why do you have reflux because you don't
have enough stomach heads should be
called lack of acid reflux because you
don't have no stomach acid there are
three functions of stomach cancer number
one your capsules and intrinsic factor
can't work to help you absorb B12
without you get your P you need your pH
variance it needs to be below two one
being the most acid four TV the most
absolute seven neutral you start getting
up towards neutral four five six you're
intrinsic Badger one
because it office every month get a B12
shot
otherwise your B12 levels your blood
goes down that's because you're
restricted salt salt is the raw material
for your stomach T cells to make stomach
acid
anybody he tells you restricted salt
should be put in jail for the rest of
your life when they die of natural
causes their body should be fed to a
rabid dog the rabid dogs poop head to
another rabid dog
okay and then the second reason why you
need stomach acid is for pepsin to work
pepsin is a enzyme your stomach makes to
digest proteins down into individual
amino acids you don't do that you get a
new allergy every month I used to be
able to eat this all my life and now
suddenly I'm allergic to it
that's because you didn't have enough
stomach acid to break that protein down
into an individual amino acid
and then thirdly equally or even greater
importance the reason why you need to
have an acid stomach environment below
two phlo2
because it keeps your stomach sterile
bacterial viruses fungus and each won't
grow in there with a pH under two get
above three four and five stop throws in
there like in vinegar it'll grow in
there
every time you eat something it's moist
and dark and warm in there
kind of like
Silence of lambs
those moths they just love that
environment right
it was a perfect environment for those
months your stomach at a pH of four five
and six is a protein environment for
yeast and bacteria you eat stuff they
begin to ferment them immediately you
generate gas start belching and burping
up the flu of your stomach which is not
really acid it's mildly acid may be a pH
of four five or six
it tastes like vinegar you know I got
acid reflux no you got lack of acid
reflux
so we actually have a wonderful product
called ultimate enzymes it's part of our
healthy digestion pack you take one or
two of those 30 minutes no excuse me
three three and ten minutes for each
meal a couple ounces of water it
re-acidifies your stomach solves all
these problems
if you need some emergency care just in
case you have something really go bad
when you're out someplace these are
ancient Legacy peppermint oil so four or
five drops of Peppermill it's a cup of
hot water I've had people for 23 years
they couldn't even talk one pastor's
wife
um
Pastor hunter in Fort Wayne Indiana he
tells the story for the pulpit so I'm
not telling Anna school he was there
because it's the oldest black church in
in Fort Wayne Indiana he's a pastor
there and he um I was big tall you know
six foot five basketball player but he
had knee problems and diabetes and
highly pressure so I was telling what to
do for himself and his wife is sitting
next to me belching burping boy
ma'am how long have you been it's
uncomfortable I didn't want to say
anything bad so he said how long have
you been suffering like this and she
couldn't even answer he said oh she's
been like that for 12 years for 12 Years
background noise that's the way it's
been you know she has to stay downstairs
because she disrupts the church service
and she can't stay in the choir anymore
so you know she's Persona 9 ground in
the church and um said oh have you tried
pepperonauts oh yeah doctor told her you
can't have pepperonis it's too acid
so I hadn't have some with me I said
hold tight if I go over it's like one
o'clock in the morning at a hotel lobby
so I pulled a cup of hot water I put
four drops in my peppermint oil uh added
her thing I said don't drink it just
smell it I'm looking at him with one eye
like a chameleon looking at her with the
other one and I'm talking to him about
his arthritis and his high with pressure
and his diabetes what to do if they're
writing them what he needs and she's
smelling it and smelling and smelly and
she couldn't resist she took a couple of
sips I'm going to demonstrate to you
what happened like in 10 seconds after
she took those two sips
she stands both upright she says oh sure
this is
everybody's waking up lights are going
phones going off what's going on in here
she's never had reflux again
she's been taking the ultimate daily
families and taking her
peppermile she ever had kind of a
episode
wow hello you know didn't God say go
forth and be assault of the earth is
that right and doctors say don't use
salt Doctors live to be 56 God lives
forever exactly
okay so you get the drill
so the bottom line is here if you
supplement before you get sick you won't
get sick
it's kind of like maintenance your car
you put all in your car after the engine
burns up before the engine burns up
before there's your burns up do the same
thing for yourself be like me
you know the odds are you won't have to
go to doctor very often and the medical
assistant will become real humble and
hopefully we'll have nice doctors who
say you know
this this Healthy Start pack of the
healthy Bone and Joint pack of the
healthy blood sugar pack healthy
digestion pack is a lot better for my
patients than Nexium and Prilosec and
all these proton pump inhibitors and
better the bad advice of eat less and
exercise more to get rid of your obesity
it'll be better than heart transplants
and digitalis and water pills or
congestive heart failure
it'll be much better than having to deal
with kids born with terrible deformities
and and birthday pictures totally 100
preventable
but we're going to have to do it because
the doctors and the government's not
going to do it it's not going to do it
so if you think you're going to take
petition to them to move them ain't
happening
so I want to thank you very much I know
I went long but you seemed like a great
audience and you came here tonight
during the holidays so I thought I'd
give you more than just the cream here
give you some basic stuff and now you're
armed you know you can't put the genie
back in the bottle
you're very dangerous now not the fact
that you know this stuff but the fact
that doctors don't know this stuff
except the two doctors are in here
tonight they probably do a little
business before they got here so I'm
looking for people not only to help us I
mean it'd be customers uses stuff and
get rid of your problems would be
wonderful
but I'm equally interested in you
becoming one of our
sort of Physicians assistants we pay
obscene amounts of money we're publicly
traded I'm the only naturopathic doctor
who publicly traded
we're moving on up to the NASDAQ
we started out in the pink sheets and
went to the bulletin board and then we
went to the
OTC whatever it is and now we're
required to go to the NASDAQ
because this stuff worked I've been
doing it for 35 years it never fails it
never fails never
you do exactly follow the recipe exactly
it will never fail
did you want to say anything before I
answered a few questions or give away a
few things to the giveaway yeah sure oh
go ahead don't forget we're gonna give
away a few items thank you very much
[Applause]
three questions in a few seconds
okay we have your ticket ready we're
going to call out some numbers
eight one five oh five nine
anybody have that somebody's got to have
it dude go for it girl
all right
how old are you young fella
13. I have four brothers who started me
with it when they were 10 to 14 years of
age I was 14 years ago all four of them
were millionaires now in our business
so you really want to consider doing
this it's a one-time fee at 10 bucks
your parents will help you out a
one-time fee of 10 bucks you become a
student of this information
by the time you're 16 years old you'll
be able to pay for your own car pay for
your own car insurance that would be a
burden off your family
815-058
thank you
all right see it's worth sitting in the
front row yeah
okay
one more giveaway okay
eight one five oh five zero
all right all right
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you
anyone have questions for the doc let me
put one more file and you almost forgot
it here in a second because underneath
that stuff let me put this away before I
do forget it
okay let's take 20 30 minutes we'll
answer questions we'll start out there
yes sir yeah
well I've got a few questions so I can't
have you had any success
people who have had peripheral
neuropathy
that have regained normal feeling in
that extremity absolutely we do this a
thousand times a day to do it for 35
years is a very simple disease it's a
back problem we have peripheral
neuropathy it's always a back problem
how much have you shrunk since you were
20 years old how much are you showing
tonight I already have I don't believe
you no I
literally I'm six foot tall as things I
wasn't eating okay anybody here six foot
tall exactly
come up here please
do you look taller than six foot two
today yeah you got big shoes yeah okay
to stand back to back
uh he has a little bit taller than six
years old he's got thicker soles on him
oh yeah okay so okay but you have
degenerative disc disease is your
problem
what happens is when they vertebrate
get closer together
They smash the roots
of the exposure is coming out from
between the the lumbar vertebrae when
you lay down at night you go to sleep do
you get pretty crawling in your legs or
cramps or anything like that no I used
to I it's been about 15 years ago that I
discovered I had this the doctor told me
it'll only get worse the memories
yeah and he also told me I was uh
ridiculous because I was reading a few
months I started reading up on it and
changed my job pretty good and
went to using no alcohol at all to go
alcohol is one of the worst things now
anyway
right now my weight is about
285 okay close enough to 200 pounds to
your perfect candidate you want to write
this down your perfect candidate and
so you guys so I need somebody here to
write this down for them sure absolutely
now do you have anything else I need to
know about high blood pressure diabetes
anything like that
[Music]
I'm mildly diabetic it's kind of like
being pregnant is anybody mildly
pregnant well
I'm not as diabetic as I was when I
discovered I was diabetic yeah because
you're working on for diet that's good
but you're still a diabetic yeah and
people say well I got under control of
drugs no you don't you can have your
blood sugar under control you're still
going to die diabetes
under control with diet and exercise it
doesn't matter it's not like it was
before yeah so you've got the blood
sugar blood sugar is not diabetes it's a
symptom of diabetes
so you can still get your symptom under
control just like you have brain cancer
you take an answer and you kill the pain
brain
have you solved your problem no are you
going to solve the symptoms right okay
so he needs two healthy Bone and Joint
packs per month they can pull those
earlier breakfast pull those early to
dinner it'll be allowed by the two
healthy bony joint painter mode
and that'll also allow you to have 15
glucogel capsules a day five at
breakfast five at lunch five at dinner
and that's to rebuild the disc here back
even if it's a millimeter or two per
disc push them apart and
relieve the pressure off of those roots
those Founders coming out from the
three-year vertebrae now there will be
two canisters
um two Wide Mouth Jars of CM cream one
with each of the healthy bone joint
packs you have your lovely wife here put
on your lumbar right down the middle two
or three times a day and about an inch
on either side so it could be a space
about that big about two inches wide
right down the middle from your last rib
down to your tailbone kind of thing and
it'll relieve a lot of that inflammation
a lot of times you'll get relief just
even before you regrow the disc between
the vertebrae just from relieving the
inflammation swelling okay and it'll all
go away
that quickly very quickly usually 60 90
days is gone
very quick never fails never fail a
pretty bold statement anybody else had a
question
this way in the back
when does epigenics come out epigenics
can come out in March all this stuff is
in this book coming out in March again
I'm very excited about this because this
um as part of the contract this
Publishing Company
is obligated to get this on every TV
program and radio and newspapers and
University lecture series and all kinds
of stuff this is they really had their
scientific committees look at this and
say this is a landmark book and so
they're pouring a lot of money and
effort coming out in March and this year
uh next year thank you
anybody else questions did I wear you
out did they any more questions last
chance here okay well do you get one
more what are your slides there you you
mentioned uh telomeres and it's
something that we're hearing about now
uh could you comment on it yes
um there's a thing called a hayflick
limit if you read the book rare Earth's
Vine cures which came out in 1994 I
talked about the hayflick limit which is
a guy by the name of Leonard hafling
he's an MD kind of a geriatric kind of
guy he was always looking at longevity
and he believed in in cell culture the
cells will only divide 51 times and they
were dead they just couldn't go anymore
and he attributed he started looking at
the telomeres and every time a cell
would divide into cell culture it would
lose a little bit of length as telomere
and by the time the 51
we came along 51 duplications the
sellers did because there's no more
telometers left they didn't quite know
what to do about it but that was back in
the 60s
and then in 2009 the Nobel Prize was
given
for the people who understood why these
telomeres shortened every time they sell
is duplicated and they came up with
theories of this and the other how you
prevent that from happening we began
working on that and we actually worked
with um
Clemson University in Clemson South
Carolina in normal human cell cultures
for just this very thing we used our
products and guess what
it just worked like a charm unlimited
endless Communications restore your
telomeres restore them they never go
away they ever go away
and so we actually came out with an
additional product that just focuses on
that one subject it's knee released
um uh what is it Wednesday or tomorrow
all right yeah tomorrow is tomorrow New
Year's Eve yes because it's really smart
two o'clock four o'clock something like
that you can go look on our schedule of
all the conferences and everything we do
so it's either two o'clock or four
o'clock is going to be released I can't
I'm under obligation under threat of
death I can't tell you the name of it um
of course it's all been trademarked
patented we've had all this we've had
literally millions of dollars worth of
research done by big universities
private companies this is heavy stuff
and this prevents the telomeres from
going away every time the cell
duplicates okay so I started taking two
of them twice a day it's not something
you're gonna get energy like energy
drink or anything like that it's one of
those things you take forever your
engine doesn't burn up okay so I started
taking them about a week ago
and you know you're not going to tell
any difference except you're going to
slowly get younger because the telomeres
that have been damaged or shortened
before on the sneeze here in a second
excuse me
will actually grow back to normal if you
have some damaged cells they're looking
to go the wrong direction this this
tablet actually has two pieces to it in
one piece knocks off the injured dead
cells it can't be helped the other piece
helps your telomeres regrow I mean it's
really a great little system and this is
coming out it's to add to the 90
essential nutrients since it's the other
piece because we're so excited about it
and
once it's out and everybody knows about
it I'm going to start doubling up
instead of taking four day electric
doses for 150 pound man or woman I'm
going to start taking a today instead of
four I'm going to take four twice a day
instead of two twice a day because I I
point out the center field and so I've
got to get there right
New Jersey I can't yes sir
further uh depression yes
there's two things you had to worry
about the prostate one is enlargement
you get up at night you take a pee uh
you have a struggle getting a stream
going we have to urinate and all kinds
of stuff like that because prostate
cancer I'll start with prostate cancer
um
nobody ever dies from prostate cancer It
Never Kills You
when you get treated for prostate cancer
it's always a treatment that kills you
causing cancer will never kill you it
never goes to your liver your lungs or
your brain
it goes regionally to your bones your
pelvis your thigh bows your femurs your
vertebrae kind of goes into this area
here whatever goes in an argument where
it's going to kill you it's a treatment
that always kills you so even even the
FDA says oops you may want to reconsider
treatment for for prostate cancer but
doctors who are oncologists they keep
pushing it because that's how they make
their money that's how they pay the
tuition for their kids to go to Harvard
so then you have student loans right
um 85 percent of the men who die after
85 have prostate cancers usually the
size of the head of a pin has not
metastasized anywhere the PSA is like 12
and so forth they've got probably can't
put it on the earlier they die of a hard
tackle to having sex with a 20 year old
you know those kind of stuff and so they
get hit in a car accident and die or
fall off the roof while they're painting
the house but they don't die prostate
cancer no prostate cancer Never Kills
You
but what you want to do is be smart and
I'll tell you what to do about prostate
cancer nutritionally in a second because
the same thing is true for a large
prostate benign
prostate hypertrophy BPH
and this is actually caused by
nutritional efficiency what happens to
your thyroid gland when you're deficient
iodine does a shrink or get bigger
it gets bigger you get a quieter so your
deficient iodine your thyroid gland gets
big what hems your prostate gland when
you're deficiently sling you it's big
see so flame deficiency causes benign
prostate high pressure
so you take the 90 essential nutrients
if you're a man I take extra sleeping
for that very reason I don't have time
to stay in front of a toilet for five
minutes to get a stream growing and so I
take three slaying twice a day in
addition to my two Healthy Start
actually two healthy Bone and Joint
facts I'd say two um bottles a month of
Slam three bottles a month of sleep I
take three twice a day I also take
prostate effects which is a a blend of
Asian African and North American herbs
which will shrink your prostate gland
even if it's already enlarged
that support normal function of prostate
gland so I take three of those twice and
eight that's two bottles of that a month
is I go around the country I have some
of our little warehouses around so every
time I go there they have to restock me
they send the bill to my wife they
restock me right and that way no matter
where I go I always have I I take people
say why do you take three suitcases with
you we know you're going for six weeks
at a time but why do you take three
suitcases one of them is a three-month
supply of my supplements they say well
you're only going for six weeks why are
you taking a three-month Supply
you ever heard of Mountain Manitoba
in the Philippines when it erupted they
grounded airplanes there for three
months
why would I die saying you know I ran
out and I couldn't get any more so I
take three months with me that way if
UPS can't run because the Grid's down or
something I get someplace they say sorry
it didn't come Wally I've got a three
month supply with me
I pointed out to center field I can't
afford I'm obsessive
so I'm prepared to pay extra shipping
for baggage if I have to but if I go
Delta Airlines I apply with them so much
I get three bags free and so when I go
Delta which is like 90 of the time I get
my three bags for free every once while
I have to Stickney on US Air or
something like that then I got to pay
that one back I don't care
so my little prostate gland is little
it's healthy it's happy nothing better
to have your prostate gland that's right
the things you were talking about in
Costa Rica Costa Rica and in China I'm
sorry the veins you were talking about
were they have the 90th Century well
they don't go from one place to the
other they're kind of they're locally
um you know when the Earth was
solidifying there were things happening
the Earth is going around right and
um some areas there were denser amounts
of these minerals as Earth is going
around you you put a bit of chocolate in
a mixing bowl and even don't put the
blenders in there but you turn the motor
on so it's going around around what
happened to that blob of chocolate if it
starts spreading around there's some
places that have more than less and and
the same principle is true that's how
that happened and
by dumb luck some areas have a lot of
something for instance we know there's
certain areas in the world I mean I was
taught this in third grade in School
they don't teach it anymore there are
places in America that don't have much
iodine that's also they have high rated
goiter the goiter belt hello you think
that's the only mineral out of the 60
that there's there's zones that have the
U.S Geological Survey
it shows where the big concentrations of
each of these essential minerals are and
when they're deficient
oh lo and behold there's no sleep in the
soil High rate of mustard industry High
rate assistive evaporation High rate
economic heart disease
deficiency diseases
and so once you know you say well why
even worry about it just take them all
an abdominal mouth or at least
myself I take more than alcohol amounts
I the minimum might take 10 times or
someone might take 10 times like RC I
take 10 times
the minimum amount because there's a
bell-shaped curve that's getting up
there where it's almost toxic but I
don't care
I'd rather have 10 times the minimum
daily requirement it's an essential
nutrient prevents certain types of
leukemia that reverse certain types of
leukemia why do I want to wait till I
get it yeah
um some things like
um oh
LED is thought to be toxic it is there's
a bell-shaped curve not enough you're
going to get a deficiency here RNA will
duplicate right without lead in small
amounts you're totally late you notice
that the FDA and the EPA never say where
we're going for a lead-free environment
they always say you got to be
below 28 parts per million or whatever
it is right that's because you need it
you need some there's a bell-shaped
curve you don't have any you get this
disease there's an alcohol and then you
get too much it's poison same thing with
water there's more people in America die
from water intoxication every year not
drowning but water and types okay they
drink too much too fast it dilutes out
the potassium and they die of heart
Salvage
water taxation more people dive that
every year during hot weather than
anything else wow water intoxication and
so nobody wants to die of something you
can prevent and so I don't you know I
don't regularly take rat poison but by
taking our supplements
we've been doing this I mean people have
been doing it for hundreds of years
before we came along the Indian tribes
are using this stuff that's how we
learned about it and so we figured out
based on animal studies and human
studies what you need to do to make this
perfect and we made it perfect we've
been doing this for 35 years and I've
been taking at least in some cases 28
000 times memory requirements so the
Waterside will think like B vitamins and
things I'm not going to get congestive
Hearts they're not going to get Quartz
cups in their own yes I have skin
problems like psoriasis
I know from here you also have a copper
deficiency you know raging copper
deficiency which contributes to the skin
problems
um but you also have
um for instance any spirains or varicose
veins spider veins varicose yeah very
common goal varicose here and you could
even have hemorrhoids which are varicose
veins in funny places these are all
caused by copper deficiency
even more scary aneurysms that are up
here
coronary arteries ARS aneurysms are
caused by copper deficiency the
breakdown of the elastic fibers and
blood vessels there's low pressure in a
vein so you just get you get spider
veins and varicose veins or hemorrhoids
there's high pressure in an artery so
you get blowouts
pollinators right just like you hit a
chock hold your tire and you break the
cords in there that's caused by copper
deficiency if you're at high risk for an
aneurysm but you have white green silver
here that's why you have varicose veins
because you have white grains over here
the same thing causes migraines over
here a copper deficiency causes aneurysm
now you're high risk for koi sealed
Jacob's disease which is the name for
human version of mad cow disease mad cow
disease is not caused by prions it's
caused by copper deficiency okay all
this stuff is coming out in this book
what do you recommend do you have
products oh yeah we have the you're a
big guy you want two healthy heart I
have to take two healthy heart and brain
patch or two Healthy Start packs and
then you throw in three of our slim
three times a day why slain it's not
asleep if there's a copper fit as well
so they put lots of copper or selenium
because it's a co-factor necessary for
the same door properly
so that's how you're gonna get the most
selenium is by taking six of our slam
today the most coppers is to take Trace
lamb at breakfast in there that's two
bottles a month and I would take two of
the healthy heart and brain packs or two
Healthy Start packs per month plus extra
copper which is in the sleeve your hair
color will come back but you got to be
on a gluten-free diet the psoriasis will
go away usually the guy you're HIV three
to six months will go away
but the dog in the house the cat
everybody living in your house wife
sister kids grandkids Grandma
mother-in-law everybody's got to be
gluten free because just
cross-contamination laundry the couch
the rug the food preparation the surface
will get you yeah okay thank you uh who
is not answering a question yet yes
um
see brain cleaner the night and the
doctor said that she should just wait
until like vision
to blurrier for me but is there
something absolutely no I'm assuming
this is in the pituitary gland you know
the benign tumors or the territory
glands how old is this person okay
is it male or female
you see how many other sort of problems
that may or may not be related to this
like does she dripped milk out of her
breasts either she have have a pressure
does she have diabetes
no this is this is enlargement every
okay yeah so here's what here's what I
do get on a gluten-free diet anything
going on with the brain you got to get a
lot of gluten-free diet no wheat brought
around oats no fried food no processed
meats and nitrates and nitrites no oils
what does she weigh she big or little
one says okay then she needs two healthy
heart and brain packs per month
right and they know what this is two
healthy heart and pain patterns one pull
those back and one bowls of dinner so
here's the secret sauce for this girl
initially she's going to need 12 ACH a
day six of breakfast and six at bedtime
with a glass of water I take six twice a
day why do I do that because I don't
want these problems I want milk proven
on my breast you know
you see this little kids I get called by
destroyed grandmother's mothers every
week I got a four-year-old granddaughter
the pediatrician says she's got a brain
tumor and her pituitary is benign
they're going to crack her head open and
take her pituitary gland out and I said
well before you consider that let me
offer you an option I have to ask you
one question
is your granddaughter or your daughter
on soy milk oh yeah she was colicky
which tells me she had a gluten and
Thomas she's colicky and so he had to
put her she couldn't tolerate breast
milk or formula so he put her on soy
milk she had a soy milk for her whole
life
well guess what's inside of
phytoestrogens the stuff you give
postmenopausal women why would you give
a four-year-old girl or a four-year-old
boy the same thing you know close
menopausal woman for phytoestrogen it's
an insane thing now tofu which is
fermented so he doesn't give the problem
no problem like that in China
we give them soy milk it's a totally
different problem because it's not
fermented
so I've got to get all the soy milk all
soy okay and
that the double dose of the it'll say
six capsules a day so you're gonna go
through two canisters a month of the HGH
six in the morning a little glass of
water six bedtime glass of water it'll
give the pituitary everything it needs
from Ramen shows but she got to take a
gluten-free diet so she can absorb it
right
they'll all go away I'm glad the doctor
said he's smarter than the average bear
because he said let's not give you tasty
here let's wait
um
coming out tomorrow how many would a
person take if they already have a
cancer problem uh Panthers
agree with you the person already has a
cancer problem I would kind of dull or
triple the dose because this stuff is
designed to knock off the bad cells and
support
longevity and health of the good cells
was sort of
crowd out the bad stuff right
um so I'll tell you what they weighed
him take two Healthy Start packs a month
they weigh 150 to 220 pounds they weigh
300 pounds be three Healthy Start packs
they need three selenium twice a day for
100 pounds evaluate and also give them
the um
I can't I gotta be careful in that name
the product the Z radical which is a
different thing and I'd give them two
ounces a day for 100 pounds of body
weight they get diarrhea cut it to one a
day but start them out with two twice a
day with a z radical and then when this
new product comes out tomorrow I'd order
that for them immediately and at least
give them
four day two twice a day would be
minimum I go whatever they can afford
and comfortable it wouldn't hurt
nope
remember there's a bell-shaped curve and
we're talking about based on Cell
cultures we're talking about the average
dose that did a job here myself I'm
pointing out the center field so I'm
doubling and tripling at 128 000 times
that kind of stuff I wouldn't do 28 000
times the minimum dose of arsenic it
doesn't too much that might knock me off
but I can do 10 times the minimum daily
requirement of RC
trademark but I can't give it out until
tomorrow oh okay I wonder if you thought
you'd get me didn't you
yeah my friends yeah right
how is rice milk and almond milk by
comparison to this one it should be
against the law for them to be called
milk yeah because there's a lot of poor
people who cause malnutrition their kids
oh they're allergic to milk so I gave
them almond milk no supplementation the
kid winds up with every disease you can
think of because there's fat and
calories and maybe a little bit of this
little bit out of there but it's not the
equivalent of nutritional milk
should be against the law to call soy
milk almond milk rice milk milk which
the rice drink almond drink or something
like that sure it is
soy worse than almond and rice or can
you say or well you can't say it depends
where it's grown okay but just it
shouldn't be used as a formula
replacement for babies I'd go from cow's
milk or breast milk to goat's milk goes
from actually designed for a four pound
baby so it's actually much better those
book is actually much better for human
babies than is cow's milk was designed
for a 40 pound baby our babies can't
drink enough cow's milk you get enough
or it goes to know they can because it's
kind of very concentrated for small
babies
makes sense okay do you have a you
mentioned this product a lot tomorrow is
our website we can go through the
that'll be the name of the product
what letter does it start with
look tell us the lettersection
um
the name of the manuscript that you're
talking about the paper that you wrote
the 1200 mini paper that's in the
Smithsonian whoa it's in the Smithsonian
Institute 1200 pages is considered a
National Treasure according to the
Smithsonian Institute in fact I didn't
show it to you but these books are now
selling for ten thousand dollars a book
on on amazon.com the cheapest ones are
like 400 800 these are beat up and the
covers are falling off well they're
pristine still in the cover that opened
up and sold a plastic bag
10 12 13 000 per book
we sold when we first printed them
um by WV Saunders which was a top
medical text the publication company
back then where can I read it
without many libraries have it libraries
so they probably won't let you take it
out anymore because it's so valuable
they'll probably make you read it in
there right
um
but if you can find one online at
amazon.com for less than 300 bucks I'd
get it what's it called it's called the
diseases of exotic animals the diseases
of exoticed animals yep okay not about
fold answers
I had one guy ask me that
okay one last question from somebody
that hasn't asked one if anybody has to
ask you a question okay
definitely get yourself a copy of Dr
wallach's cookbook this is basically a
textbook teaching you everything you
know about how to cook without the bad
foods particularly oil and gluten and
all of the other problematic things on
the list this is 300 Pages stuffed full
of recipes every traditional recipe that
you could think of and modern dishes
without the bad foods that they're
usually made from and of course make
sure to check out our food page notice
Foods that's on YouTube and add notice
Foods on Instagram we have a lot of
content up there teaching you how to
cook without the bad foods that Dr
Wallach describes and Dr glidden's 12
bad foods all of that all of the rules
that you need to know and we have
experienced chefs and Bakers who will
answer the questions in those inboxes
and I've also published a book in
response to some of Dr wallach's
criticisms including the major articles
that have been written against him on
the internet so if you are a Dr Wallach
fan or a youngevity distributor I
definitely recommend having this book in
your toolkit and definitely check out my
Book fake diseases it covers all of the
major topics that come up like birth
defects blood sugar problems bone
enduring problems cancer autoimmune
problems and more and it's on Amazon for
just 9.99 and the audiobook read-along
version is free here on YouTube and the
link for that is in the description of
this video
[Music]
foreign